i'm sure most of you know
that youtube has given stephen crowder a
warning which is like a
it's a warning they don't shut you down
but they take your content down
they then gave him a strike then they
gave another warning on his other
channel crowder bits
they then gave him a second strike on
his main channel and then they gave him
a strike on a second channel this is
serious
and for anybody listening who's not
familiar crowder is a massive
personality he's a conservative comedian
he does news commentary cultural
commentary and
for the longest time we saw censorship
happening it was targeting
it was targeting the fringes so or so
many people said but as you can see as
time goes on the fringe keeps changing
the hit pieces keep coming and they just
keep coming for the next
the next person closer and closer
towards you know the center
and then eventually everyone gets
censored we even see many anti-war
leftists getting censored as well well
crowder is fighting back filing a
lawsuit or at least he's announcing he
will be filing a lawsuit
and an injunction against youtube and
it's really interesting we're gonna go
through what they're talking about why
they're doing it and i think this is
extremely important because
well once crowder goes then who's next
on the chopping block channels like ours
see before they started going after
crowder they were going after other
channels as well people like alex jones
and we all knew
it's only a matter of time before they
would make their move and slowly just
get rid of more and more content
creators more and more
channels so we definitely talk about
this and make sure we're keeping this at
the forefront because this is going to
be really really important
and i'll say it too you know we
obviously want crowder to be able to
continue doing his work and there's also
a bit of self-preservation in there
it's it's it's i know what happens to us
the moment crowder's out of the picture
they're going to keep moving down the
line we can't have that happen so we'll
talk about that
we've got a bunch of other news too
there's a huge supreme court decision
nine to zero like even the liberal
justices agreed
cops can't use caretaking as an excuse
to go in your house
and take your guns without a warrant so
we'll get into that we also got police
reform in the minneapolis area
the black lives matter activists have
won and now they're going to be creating
an
unarmed traffic enforcement division
which i can only assume will be
like i want to say like a benny hill
movie but with more
violence and and injury and it really
does worry me
so we're gonna get we're going to get
into this and joining us today is the
digital editor from recoil magazine
forest cooper thanks for hanging out man
hey tim
do you want to just give a quick
introduction for yeah no i'll do that my
name is
are you wearing i am i am showing off
some of the stuff that we
work on in our magazine but now for
reality
[Laughter]
i told him to wear it everybody he did
it was uh it was it was forced
for you i was like i was like hey put
that on yeah put that on night vision
goggles night vision right so it's
that kind of if you want to understand a
little bit about recoil magazine we like
to be edgy
in that fashion looking at new products
what's really coming out so instead of
it just being about whether a firearm
you know how evaluating a firearm we
talk about culture we talk about
night vision how to do it and so
it's it's really about education and
aspiration
youtube stuff gun stuff gun stuff yup
the core
idea being culture leads
policy you change culture by going out
and doing stuff speaking of
stephen crowder the other day we uh so
on saturday i went actually
i finally got the sig m400 that crowder
had sent to me thank you very much
stephen it's it's
and we took it out to the range in west
virginia
and everyone was super impressed with it
so we had a great time
so you know forrest and i and a few
others went out we fired a bunch of guns
and we also brought out the barrett
m82a1 and uh tried to blow up the gong
but we weren't able to do it but it was
it was fun firing that so that's what we
did yesterday yep and again the the the
weapon from from crowder was incredible
everybody was super impressed that i was
super impressed with it we're really
grateful for forgetting that so again
we're talking about the censorship stuff
we got ian eastwood what's up everybody
ian crossland good to be here
you got me in the corner pushing buttons
i'm sour patch lids
before we get started with the show go
to timcast.com
click the big members only button and
you can sign up to become a member
you can do it through stripe or paypal
see where we're building up the site
we're making it better because we know
many people have asked
but this site exists because the fear of
censorship was very real and i realized
if i didn't start setting something up
that would exist outside of youtube i
got all my eggs in one basket
and you know we can get banned the same
as crowder can so
just like crowder has the mug club which
you guys should definitely check out and
support him considering what they're
going through and how important this
lawsuit is
we have timcast.com where you can join
us as well and when you do you get
access to the members area
a ton of exclusive members only podcast
segments and full episodes it's really
really great
we were hanging out with robbie starbuck
last week talking about neocon rhinos
threatening to quit the republican party
and he made a really good point the
tumor is exercising itself oh we're so
upset about it
so definitely become a member just be
there because in the event that we get a
strike look
even one strike if we say something
wrong any moment we don't know what
we can't produce any content on any
channel for a week
same thing is happening to crowder right
now they got him out for two weeks
so in the event that uh in the event
that happens you can find us at
timcast.com but don't forget to like
share subscribe hit that notification
bell if you're listening on itunes
spotify or any other podcast platform
give us a good review
and uh you know take the url on youtube
and share it around it really really
does help especially considering
this is the big fight everybody let's
talk about this first story right here
louder with crowder.com officially suing
youtube stephen crowder initiates legal
action against youtube
from crowder's website they report last
week louder with crowder llc through its
lawyer gave a legal notice to youtube
of the intent to file a lawsuit and seek
an injunction
they go and mention they have a video
available on their website last fall
after the vox adpocalypse youtube
remonetized crowder's channel
they said we had a record-breaking
election livestream in november
and incredibly successful streams
thereafter if there ever was a target
painted on our backs it was then
once we hit the new year and a new
president ascended the landscape of
social media shifted in favor of the
left
democrats took control the presidency
and now have control of both house
houses of congress as such youtube and
other big tech platforms feel emboldened
with very few lawmakers standing in the
way he says
in 2021 youtube hit them with a warning
of a strike over election content
then issued the first heart strike the
first strike was related to a coveted
policy in their march 18th video
of the one-year anniversary of 15 days
to flatten the curve
the studio is familiar with youtube's
policies on covet so i'll just give you
the
the gist of it and and i went over this
the first time they gave him a strike
crowder did not break
any rules in this capacity and i got i
got really angry because
i get this email from google when this
is going down like well in advance of
any of the censorship
straight up saying here are the exact
conditions you must meet to violate this
policy and i said
that's easy they said you can't say two
specific things
together which obviously i can't say
because youtube will take us down if i
do even even
if i explain it that's the way this
works their algorithms don't understand
the difference between
explaining something and it's it's all
the same to them
crowder never said that there was
widespread fraud
crowder never mentioned about you know
anything about
overturning or anything like that they
gave him a strike
which is bunk the next one the second
one is the craziest apparently
they're claiming that crowder and his
team were glorifying the death of mikaya
bryant
for agreeing with the police
that the police officers were justified
in the shooting now of course media
matters says that they were mocking you
know uh
the woman i i don't see that as still
violating the policies which says you
know glorifying or reveling in someone's
death
when you're like hey this is the law if
you break it this is what's going to
happen
i think youtube is reaching as crowder
explains he says the concern they have
is that youtube is actively looking for
violations
in their past videos that aren't
actually violations in order to issue
a third hard strike once they're allowed
to stream to the platform
which would de-platform them from
youtube youtube has a
has a pattern of applying policies and
even stretching those policies beyond
any reasonable reading of the policy in
order to harm channels which take a
contrary view of their opinions
we experienced this we have we only ever
have ever gotten a warning
but it was our episode with alex jones
and they claimed that
a hyperbolic statement was
glorifying violence or something and
they took the they took the full podcast
down
and i said it was it was a half a second
can i just snip it out they're like no
they were they were looking for any
possible excuse to take our video down
and i think that's pretty obvious
everybody so he was going to mention
why you should care no matter what side
of the political political aisle you're
on
youtube isn't encouraging debate it's
trying to squash debate
trying to eradicate ideas from its
platform it simply does not like
one day those ideas are about the
election then they're about covid
now those ideas include applauding an
officer for saving a woman's life when
will enough be enough
well this is really important but i
gotta say to uh to steven and crew
obviously we all care i think the people
who watch this show care about
principle and recognize the kami is
going to have their free speech the
nazi's going to have their free speech
and we're going to be annoyed with them
but we're going to argue and that's the
purpose of free speech we want our
rights protected
and that means people you don't like are
they they get rights too
the problem is the plea the people were
up against i hate to call it left and
right because it really doesn't make
sense economically or or even
in terms of tradition versus pro
progressivism
it's just zealots who want power whose
ideology is there is no truth but power
and then people who are like let's have
a fair debate a fair argument over this
so they're suing they're filing an
injunction
and i wonder what precedent could be set
there's a lot there's a lot of people
need to understand like when you when we
watch james o'keefe filing these
lawsuits against the new york times and
cnn
a lot of people say you can't do it you
can't do it for this that mysteries i
know it's gonna get thrown out
it you can only do it until you do it if
you keep backing down and saying
there's no point in suing because oh
what's going to happen it's going to be
a waste of money okay listen
i understand if you don't have the money
to file a lawsuit that's a challenge
but if you just sit there and let these
companies do this
there will never be precedent set so
i'll throw it to you guys otherwise i'm
gonna keep ranting on
the censorship uh you know ian obviously
you you were talking about
just before the show creating terms of
service for minds because you helped put
that together yeah honestly in addition
to
it being up against you know like you
said zealots people that are just like
kind of
kind of crazy about political
correctness and stuff we're also up
against centralization of power and algo
machine learning algorithms that aren't
necessarily and we're seeing the flaws
in the system of a centralized service
that's dictating what can and can't be
said through a machine algorithm because
stuff gets taken out of context like you
said you can't explain certain things
even though you're not using it
derogatorily because the the the voice
to text thing they do for captions would
just show the sentence
it doesn't understand i'm like here's
exactly what youtube said i can't say
they'd be like
we see it in the code gone yeah you see
this also in like the firearms industry
or the gun world so there's there's
guntubers people who make
youtube videos you could say grand
thumb's a big one warrior poet society
is a good one um
hitchcock 45. hickok he's great he's
classic yeah i love that
so but i mean you can the so the
firearms industry actually in some ways
not the industry but the community
because
culture as well with some and somewhat
saved by the internet because it allowed
people from
rural areas because a lot of more
firearms ownership in rural areas
communicate with one another and then
they started making youtube channels how
so that people could
learn how to do things and it is
ironically controversial
in the united states right now i don't
want to use ironically too heavy because
it's way too hipster
but it's you're right though yeah right
no but it's it's ironically
controversial that a person can have
their page taken down
because they were teaching somebody how
to not hurt themselves
do you remember when google banned the
word gun yes
this was the best thing because uh so
you couldn't search for the word or
or any combination of the three letters
g-u-n yep
so i searched for the anime gundam yep
it wouldn't come up
you couldn't buy japanese action figures
that's how stupid their censorship is
yeah like my personal
my personal instagram is at foxrow
official and my
search page is all gundams
and motorcycles because it's like you
look at my page i've got
guns and motorcycles but my search
history if you look at the search base
it's all gundam it's all and it's all
anime characters why are you searching
for that it's just defaulting it well i
mean i did play final fantasy vii once
great oh there you go yeah right one of
the best
the remake was good i enjoyed the remake
yeah
but that's like anyway google uh only re
like a lot of people were so we went to
the range yesterday we're filming the
vlog and we fired
the barrett uh was it uh m82 a1
that's the kind of nomenclature that
people use yeah and uh 50 bmg
and the and and crowder gave uh he sent
me a year ago
a sega m400 and i also got a a sig
uh tread sight and uh it was amazing it
was just really really great and we did
it all we did it all safe i mean
forrest you clearly know how to shoot
we're giving instruction we also had the
instructor on
on site and a lot of people were just
like i i got asked like 10 times are you
sure you can do this
like youtube will delete your vlog won't
and i'm like i went through the rules
they say as long as you're showing the
weapon and shooting it
in a range i mean obviously there are
youtubers who are still producing but
i don't know maybe we'll get the channel
demonetized yeah i mean there's
different types of content you can see
people creating either it's just
like short films people do that with all
the time with usually with airsoft guns
but you get the point
um but they also do how to like how to
disassemble a firearm so you can clean
it
so when you're your channel your video
gets demonetized because you're teaching
somebody how to
safely clean their firearm you're
getting dinged with something that says
you're teaching someone how to us
to manufacture assemble right
which is which is which is one of those
things where like
the the the the people who are running
the asylum are not the right people
kind of thing yeah it's it's it's
contradictory
when it's it's you're watching people
perform
gun safety and so they punish you for it
yes so one of the things they said is
that uh you can only show a weapon in
appropriate place like
a gun store or a range you can't just
have one in like an office room or
something i guess they'll give you a
strike
sure you could so uh there's a local
range out here
and they have they have rooms that look
just like classrooms because they do
safety trainings
yeah you can't do that no no they'll be
like oh wow that's not
you know it looks too much like this
right we'll take it looks like a school
it could be yeah and then you're gonna
get in trouble you're gonna get
dangerous censored
and uh and there lies the big problem i
love how you said it was ironic because
america is it's a gun country and these
massive services
namely youtube will ban your content and
i i have to wonder too
there's there's there's definitely an
overlap here obviously you know crowder
is usually he got i think what is it
what does he have the walther on his
yeah on his desk he's got a walther yeah
uh-huh and uh i wonder
i i cuz i've always been curious about
that i'm like dude's got a gun sitting
on his desk
or he or he's wearing he's got his
holsters and i'm just like i
i'm pretty sure there's some you know
democrat
anti-gun person sitting at youtube hq in
silicon valley with their finger over
the band button just like your stupid
gun
more on gun you and then they're just
waiting they're waiting like like
crowder said they're looking for
something to get him for
yeah and i think that's the part where
you establish intent like the ob
it is not really about honest
disagreement it's
look we're looking at intent now but the
bigger question is
and i'm glad crowder is finding legal
legal action this is a good thing
because like i said you've got to sue
and then
make that argument but they can ban
whoever they want whatever they want
right according to most terms i haven't
read the
youtube terms i know twitter says we can
ban you at any time for
any or no reason mm-hmm that's that's
interesting so
it's interesting now that uh we have we
we as
individuals who operate on these
platforms have no legal protections
and it's interesting maybe we shouldn't
maybe it's our own fault that's why i
set up you know timcast.com because i'm
like okay
i mean i'm fairly libertarian if youtube
has got a company they don't owe me
anything and it's their platform
if somebody came into my house and
started you know like throwing food on
the floor i'd be like
get out someone came to my house started
screaming a bunch of nazi stuff i'd be
like dude get out
not not gonna be having that the
difference is
youtube is has has been subsidized by
google they've monopolized the space
there are
platforms where you can upload videos
but
youtube is absolutely dominated and now
it's kind of the only place where you
can run a business it's a really really
complicated argument
no other service offers monetization in
the same way that youtube does
and so what's this or do they uh recoil
is currently
building and we have recoil tv which
functions
similar to youtube and we are building a
monetization path it's expensive to host
these videos though
we and we do we actually we have it so
if you are a firearms man if you're a
firearms content creator
get a hold of us because we'll put you
on recoil tv it doesn't cost you
anything oh wow yeah but but
you guys got to fund that run ads or
something or we we fund it through
the fact that people like our
publication really but it can get really
really expensive so
we so in in for instance in the members
only section of our website we have to
pay for that bandwidth and it is a lot
like it it gets up to tens of thousands
of dollars people don't realize this
youtube's free so we broadcast right now
on youtube
you know we get 40k concurrent views
you know on average during the election
we had like 140 or some on one podcast
that means for the for the two to three
megabits up we're sending out we're
sending out
a hundred and forty thousand two times
two megabits
all of that data youtube's paying for
yeah and then they take a small
percentage of super chats
they take a percentage of you know
advertisements
so so the issue is they're they're
funding the cost for all of these things
should we be entitled to the service and
that's where things get challenging and
man uh i'm pretty much on the fence but
so long
as i'm on the fence in terms of like
their business private company
but where where i draw the line is if
they've monopolized public discourse
if they have grown to this to the size
to where they're influencing elections
now i think it's
it's a it's a it's a public service and
that's that's interestingly a more
liberal argument conservatives never
used to have and i'm like
i think that they've they've grown and
taken over the commons
we don't have town hall discourse
anymore people are
coming to this show and and hearing
arguments and discussions and commenting
it's take youtube youtube's effectively
dominated the space
well now they owe they owe public
discourse
in which case i think it's extremely
dangerous if they're going to start
removing people who are setting up
maybe uh who are setting up their
businesses maybe a better way to put it
is
if a private company bought all of the
available business space in
in in downtown yeah a certain point
people are going to be like okay fine
you can own it but you can't ban people
for selling a product you don't like
like people can pay you rent you can set
up terms for the property
but we need commerce to exist crowder
needs to be able to speak we need to be
able to have reasonable discourse
and what the problem i see with this is
that massive multinational corporations
if they see youtube get away with this
they can just start to dominate whatever
public space they want whatever area of
the commons they want
and then just say but it's a private
company it's ours now
shut everybody out and then i don't know
what people get violent
well on the forefront of that you're
also looking at what is the intent again
you think about it in the sense of we
could talk about guns we can talk about
anything political even with stephen
crowder
do they not want him to be heard or do
they not trust
him as a as a good faith actor is a good
question right well
i think if you look at the the left
faction
tends to be in my opinion a there is no
truth but power faction yep
they accuse the right of being that and
it's really insane
that perhaps many of the establishment
republicans for sure
but when we're looking at anti-critical
race theory individuals and their
alignment on the right these are the
people who reject
that that ethos and so quite literally
you have the left
lying and accusing the right of what
it's doing itself which creates a
serious problem
do they think crowder is a bad faith
actor no i think they believe crowder is
truthful and they don't like it right
because they're bad faith
actors they're anger they're angry by
his success they're angry about his
success
there are a lot of leftists a lot maybe
maybe the majority who are good faith
but they're following the the bad faith
pipe piper
believing they're you know following the
truth and then they say the same thing
about trump and trump's die hard fans
and i'm like okay but that's not the
majority of whatever this faction is
yeah there are a lot of people who are
like begrudgingly voting for trump
you know and then you have a lot of
people left who begrudgingly voted for
biden
so it's interesting but in the end
people like the you know in in the
intellectual dark web disaffected
liberals
moderates have more in common with
conservatives based on moral frameworks
and rejection of critical race theory
and left identitarianism
believing in free speech than the
establishment democrats
and there's a big difference between
voting for trump and voting for biden
you vote for trump because he's a human
molotov cocktail or because you really
like him in his policies
people vote for biden because he's a
feeble old man they think they can
overtake and steal power
or they genuinely like his policies but
i believe that was probably like a tiny
faction
most of people voted for because he's
hated trump yeah based on that you
cannot build the government so
yeah what a house divided against itself
yep so i know most people have more in
common than they realize i think that's
occupy wall street showed that when
when people were railing against the
federal reserve and like the monetary
system
kind of putting us all against each
other you had to stop that it's so sad
when
people get confused and start to go at
each other like this i don't like it
yeah the no truth but power argument is
a great
form of sort of moral cynicism but it
also it's very manipulative it's not a
very
well first of all it's very honest
because the people who say it are only
interested in power so at least they're
on it
they're consistent in that sense but it
says rest in power
there is no truth but power which is how
i'm going
and i'm going to use that philosophy to
take your power and give it to me
it's not the statement there no truth
but power is not complete
it's only the first half it's there is
no truth but power
and i deserve it you know it's
interesting because
there's i understand what they're saying
when they say that
that what's the point of having an
argument with you if
if they want to create their own system
their own utopia their own leftists you
know perfect world
there's no point having an argument with
a bunch of people who disagree with them
they just need to take your power away
destroy your system and then build a new
one so for the time being
i don't i don't think the core of their
philosophy is there is no truth but
power it's
in order for me to build my utopia i
must seize all of your power and the
truth be damned
and that's where we're at right now and
it leads to some very interesting things
which is our
our next segment here actually so uh
forest you're you're based out of
minneapolis
i live in minneapolis for the time being
for the time being and you've got to see
a lot of what's been going on we got the
story from the star tribune
here we go brooklyn center passes police
reform package bravo uh black lives
matter they've won this one
the failed leadership of brooklyn center
has caved
one of the things they're going to be
doing an unarmed
civilian traffic enforcement division
here's my favorite thing civilian
police civilians technically yes
technically no
i'm i'm not going to be able to answer
that one because it's it
i think you could make the argument in
many ways that they're functionally
neither right now
functionally neither they're
functionally neither because i mean sure
they have you have
they're not citizens in the sense that
they work for the government that's
where do we make that distinction either
is another question because that's i
think that's a very modern way of
thinking
yeah because a soldier is not considered
a citizen but he's still a citizen of
the country he's a civilian
he's not considered a civilian yeah so
they but they're citizens they're
citizens civilians yeah sorry
yeah they're they're they're you know
combatants they're they're armed forces
and uh so conventionally the answer is
no
but it so i would i would i would say
that if you're talking from
a military perspective the answer is yes
they're not going in foreign war they're
literally living in a small town and
dealing with local domestic law
they're civilians so the line gets
blurred because you have you have when
you talk about the police
you're you're talking about a very large
swath of people
right you've got your small town sheriff
and you've got
you know cia you've got fbi you've got
bortak you've got people who have who
are much more look much more militant
than most people don't see them and
they're are they both considered the
police
well so let's let's get in the meat
potatoes here they they've successfully
reformed their police and it's
it's beyond what i would consider
because i've said we need reform but i'm
usually talking about
creating more divisions like an unarmed
traffic enforcement
okay well maybe if the idea uh
if the idea is like you see someone
commit a traffic violation you write
down their license plate and they mail
them a ticket
that's something they've been talking
about doing but what do you think would
happen if
someone you know an unarmed civilian
tries pulling over
let's say there's a guy and maybe he's
at a party
and he wakes up and he's got a gun and
he goes to one of the people
who owns like one of the people who
lives there and then he says give me all
your money and then shows that he's got
a gun
let's say that's that's the person and
now this person is wanted for that crime
which is a funny
let's say they're driving and the
unarmed person pulls them over
for by whatever means the division is
able to do it the lights turn on i guess
they have some kind of car
and they get out what do you think
happens to a person in a situation like
this
you do have a disparity of power and you
also have a disparity of the duty so the
is it the duty of the unarmed civilian
to pull somebody over
or is it just a privilege of their
position
right so please please stop yeah i mean
you're powerless to employ it but are
you is there the burden the onus of the
state on you to go do it do you have a
quota
oh well there's more people drunk
driving in our neighborhood right now
yeah they are they're all armed and i'm
not right you're like what are you going
to do voters are bad
you know so it's the bureaucratic
problem i feel like this is the
opening the door to defund the police
completely one of the and it's kind of
funny too because
one of the ways police get funding is
through tickets and i'm not a fan
especially when they do quotas
yeah so now it's like they're being
defunded by taking away their ability to
issue traffic violations
i think it can be seen as a lot more
sinister too so you take your example
earlier
you they they see you commit a a
violation or they
put up traffic cameras and they see you
run a red light then they send a ticket
to your house which you cannot fight
or if you try to fight it it's going to
cost you time and money so you just
sort of now have to pay it but most
people do but if you don't
then they send armed people with guns to
your house
now you have a position of creating that
pipeline of going from um
i don't like you i write you a ticket
for something that could be bogus could
be legitimate
it goes to your house knowing that
you're not going to pay it
and then you instead of you and then and
then
you don't fight this is bro we're
starting now they can search your house
now they can search your house now they
can seize your property this is called
um look at what this is already in
effect in london
wow right you go to london you run a red
light you park in the wrong place you
will have a ticket sent to your house
and you can't fight it well you can and
then if you don't pay it the cops show
up
and now you've got some kind of crime
they can let us in
it creates a paper trail it's it's it's
um it's crime by bureaucracy not now if
if they pull you over while you're
driving you get taken don't pay they can
still go to your house and arrest you
and go into your house
yes but there was somebody there to
witness it that is the purpose of
american policing is that a person
has to do it i think though in the end
this would increase the likelihood of
these because
i once got uh i once got in the mail two
tickets
from chicago final determination they
said and i was like
what is this i had gotten two parking
tickets for parking outside of my dad's
place in chicago but i had a permit
i had a parking permit i guess a cop
somebody
wrote me two tickets never put them on
my car
i never got notice of them until it was
a final determination
and so when i got it i called and said
what is this i have a permit to park
where i did they were like sir it's too
late you lost your chance to fight the
ticket
so imagine you get pulled over all right
let's
you get pulled over you get to take it
you don't pay they can eventually come
to your house maybe to serve a warrant
for failure to appear or something like
that
but let's say you never even knew you
did anything wrong let's say you didn't
do anything wrong
let's say you were driving right and one
of these unarmed people was just like
hey blew a stop sign as far as i'm
concerned
you get you got to take in the mail you
never realize it came in the mail you're
like i don't know these are you throw in
the trash
then one day they show up at your house
and you're like what's happening
when there's when there's an interaction
between you and the officer
i think there's you know likelihood
you're going to be aware of what's
happening
this will probably increase the
likelihood cops start showing up to
people's homes
and i can only imagine that would
maintain the same
ratio of violent encounters it's not
going to get better that's for sure
i mean it's not it's because now you're
going to take the
the cultural perception of the police as
a threat
in certain areas and you're going to
cross that you're going to paint that
across the whole
population right but apparently i was
reading this and they they are going to
pull people over
yes so i can only imagine that people
are going to be like you get pulled over
and a guy walks up in like a polo and
khakis and he's like
excuse me sir you are speeding i'm
supposed to write you a who are you a
cop
no sir i'm i'm not a cop later yeah or
what obligation do i have to stop for
someone's not a cop i mean are you just
going to look back in your mirror and
say it's a red and yellow light not a
red and blue light so i might as well
just drive home
oh i live in a gated community you're
not allowed in here so if you come in
here i'm gonna call the actual cops to
tell you to not come in
i think it's funny i think it's funny
these people go around like smashing up
windows starting fires
we saw what happened right right now in
minneapolis they're they're
people are freaking out they're
demanding more cops they're increasing
the budgets and then this one town
brooklyn center which is like north
you just like basically do north all of
a sudden they're like we're gonna do the
opposite
we're gonna we're gonna you know car
blanche yeah i mean brooklyn center is
gonna get eaten by
minneapolis it's gonna get folded in i
mean has that happened recently
is it because folded in like it's it's
it's it's within the counties
it brooklyn center is is essentially
minneapolis
so what's what's it like living in
minneapolis is it is the apocalyptic
wasteland we all uh believe it is
because we watch nothing but internet
videos
it's not completely the apocalypse
apocalyptic wasteland um it's not the
but but it is basically uh
cobble it's closer to mosul yeah it
feels a lot more like being in kandahar
than it does like being in america
but do you mean that for real like yeah
i mean it's not quite the same i'm not
driving an armored vehicle around
but i definitely there are definitely
like we have new sop standard operating
procedures amongst us and our friends
and our family like i think
you actually served though you were yeah
i was in the military
so so just probably a lot of people like
he has no idea what he's talking about
minneapolis
like no you're actually no i i have had
the uh
privilege of being in the armed forces
for a while that's a great time what did
you do in the military i was a ranger
army ranger
so it was a great time so now uh being
back home
and uh it's like what similar
not it's not as bad yeah i mean no one's
burning tires uh
to block the roadways for three months
of the year
there's an autonomous zone where they're
like we do have an autonomous barricades
and threaten people with violence
so in the same way there are places that
we just don't go
like there are roads you don't take no
go zones there's there's there is
there's definitely like
hey i we communicate my family we
communicate and it's like hey i'm going
to go get groceries okay cool
i mean that's kind of normal for some
people but we're definitely more
conscious
about what we're looking at what what
threats we're looking for what kind of
concerns we have and then we have a
little network of people
that we that are all friends and
families in in the twin cities that
we're all looking out for each other is
this
new like this behaviors and these these
offensive
tactics it absolutely initiated last
year when the riot started
we it was we spontaneously set it up we
just called all the people that we knew
we built a
kind of a network through social media
conversation or through signal or
through
text messages and we established ways
that we talked to each other
so that we could very effectively
verify rumors so one of the worst things
that happened during the riots
last year not this year was essentially
the entirety
of social media became
an advertisement for non things that
aren't happening the
the white supremacists are coming down
from new brighton the these people are
coming from here we just saw this thing
happen
and it was like everyone was on so high
alert that they were
spreading rumors so quickly which added
to the fervor it added to the
the terror in the sense and so what the
first thing one of the things that we
had to do as a community is
by our own volition by our own choice
verify information ourselves
so okay if someone's saying that the the
this is on fire or they're
moving towards one of the one of the
concerns that they had last year was
if the police provide a strong enough
presence
in defending of precinct or they harden
targets in like heart when they mean
harden target like
make it difficult for people to loot and
riot in certain areas they're going to
move into
the residential areas so the moment we
heard that it was like okay how can we
verify that information
because that sounds a lot like hearsay
but it also has a big threat
so you're basically creating like a
neighborhood watch is that what happened
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's it's an
honor yeah it's a neighborhood watch
unofficial it's like you know your
chat group remember when i was talking
about this
maybe like a week or two ago when i said
what's going to start happening is
there's more violence
you'll see the formation of like local
community groups exactly
they'll start texting each other hey i
heard this are you all right text you
know there'll be text groups
and it's going to escalate from there
yeah and we took it a step further of
having triggers and conditions
or conditions and appropriate responses
so like in the event that x happens we
do y
right in the event that we see this
happens so like if the protest goes to
this precinct we go to this person's
house and get their wife and child out
and move them out of the city to put
them into a safe house
and we did that we had to do we had to
do exactly that you mentioned earlier
said for the time being
so you're getting out aren't you yeah
we're looking at moving out of state
there's not there's not a i mean our
families are
are there but there's not a lot of
reason to live in minneapolis right now
it doesn't it does not look like a
bright future
everybody's going to texas i guess texas
is a big one
yeah it's kind of crazy when you when
you mention like these streets you don't
go down
that's like a new thing since the start
of the riots that's why i asked you yeah
i mean the term minnesota nice is not
entirely
pejorative it also does mean that like
generally speaking you can drive through
most of the city and not be
in actual fear for your life but when i
go to a place and i see a roadblock with
armed
people that just by looking at them know
that they have no idea what they're
doing with that firearm
given it's their right to have it but i
know that they're not gonna they don't
know what they're doing with it i'm not
gonna put myself in the position
of no reward and all risk i want to show
you guys this uh
this post i found on reddit so i'm
browsing reddit
and uh political humor okay if you go on
reddit and you click all
you'll see every post it is a
hive of scum and villainy it's just a
lot of people who are really dumb
they don't do research it's very tribal
political humor this is one of the front
page posts
it says radical left it shows the k
a photo from the capitol and says it
cracks me up when the left is referred
to as radical
as if the left is running around
carrying assault rifles
denying science and discussing not
accepting the election results
and i'm like does any of these people
have the internet four years ago
like four or four years did they use the
internet first of all okay
fair point no one is running around with
assault rifles
that's just stupid nope no one not not
anyone i mean
it'd be kind of a crazy thing to see a
guy running around with like an actual
m16 or
maybe even like a legit belt fed machine
gun of some sort
but no uh no one's doing that i think
they just mean rifle in general
okay well uh the left is doing that
substantial like a hundred times more
often
than the right does it they've been
denying science and the election for
four years
but these people they live in a bubble
yep i think it's funny i i want to bring
this up because you're mentioning
minneapolis
you know you live there and i'm like
they got they i was reading a story
where it was like 30 gunshots ring out
at like 10 p.m and then it's like by 11
pm another 30 gunshots ring out
guys on a rooftop they say start
tripping i think it was an op-ed it's a
guy on a rooftop with an assault rifle
and i'm like
it's probably just a regular rifle but i
get your point there's a guy in a roof
with a gun i've seen the picture and i i
know where the gunshots happened because
yeah so what's going on what's going on
as autonomous zone so in the autonomous
zone from what i understand
and this is going to be a combination of
um
it's a difficult thing it's a difficult
piece to explain entirely but what you
have is essentially people thinking that
the cops are going to come in and raid
their buildings
so you'll have like when you the picture
that we're talking about was
classically a guy on a rooftop with an
ar-15 style rifle
sitting up there like he's providing
overwatch for the city right or for for
the neighborhood so in case a police
officer or the police come down or
whatever maybe it's
something this guy wanted to shoot cops
we don't i can't i'm not going to
ascribe
that i can't i can't tell you what he
wanted but maybe he was genuinely afraid
for his neighborhood maybe he was afraid
that a
rival gang was going to do something i i
don't know but i do know that when you
you can if you go out into minneapolis
at night and you go into the right air
neighborhoods you will find people on
rooftops with guns you will find people
but that's just like rooftop koreans
right like people who want to protect
their businesses
um i in some cases i'm assuming yes but
let's let's just hope so
there was i typed them from who though
right right is the uh
you can make the argument that the
autonomous zone is trying to protect
their
people from cops taking in you could say
that
people in that area were trying to
protect their own business these people
are insane about cops like do you know
what happens i'm going to let everyone
in a big secret and this is
going to shock a lot of people you know
what happened if you were in the big
city
and you just like walking down the
street and there were two cops in front
of you and they're walking on the street
you know what happened if you walked
past those cops
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
it's like
i'm chicago is notorious for its bad
cops
we had a video where like this cop
grabbed or another video with a story
about a cop
grabbed a meter maid because she was
writing about it he parked illegally she
wrote a ticket so he grabbed her by the
throat and lifted her up and slammed her
against the wall chicago was notorious
for for crooked cops and i see a cop on
the street i'm like howdy
hey yeah these people are like put up
barricades we need guns there are police
they're hunting us
they're really delusional man but i'll
mention this
i think it was in philly during the
riots there were people tweeting like
hey stay away from this neighborhood
there's a bunch of
you know far right guys on roofs with
guns on rooftops with guns
and they post a photo of a bunch of
dudes on roofs with guns all the
businesses were safe yep
no uh we saw we encountered a place in
minneapolis that
uh this last year if you looked at um
new brighton and where all the looting
was
um we got to i got to meet some people
that it was it was four guys outside of
a tobacco shop
um and they all had they all had ak-47s
and they're just chilling there because
that was one of two buildings that did
not get looted in the area and the good
news is the left only wants to ban
i'm sorry i shouldn't say the left the
democrats only want to ban air 15. so
aks are totally fine
yeah let's hope so yeah no no because
there are i mean
who was it was it we already instituted
a ban of russian-made aks like import
bans is a big issue
right right right right so the good news
is a lot of companies have moved their
manufacturing into the united states
but that is a it's a back door i just i
just think it's funny when they tweet
all day
like uh you know we gotta ban ar-15s no
one should have what i'm like
i'll get an ak got it buddy thanks
thanks do you know do you know anything
about what you're saying because it's
meaningless
yeah you gotta ask the question every
once in a while with uh
gun control is is it ignorance or is it
malice those are two different things
yeah it's definitely mouse oh yeah and
at one point in time does ignorance
become malice because if you look at the
foray of
data that we have in any relating to gun
violence and gun control i mean it's not
a hard argument to make the problem is
that it
you've made it so many times that no one
cares anymore all the ma the big
violence happens in places where there's
gun control
perhaps we should start making the
conclusion that gun control begets
violence
and i think malice so obviously
nothing's absolute there's probably a
lot of ignorant people who just follow
along
but it's got to be malice and you need
to understand this when you make the
same argument
800 000 times and they don't care and
keep lying
okay it's not ignorance anymore like
when someone says that stupid meme you
know no self-respecting hunter would use
an assault weapon
and then you're like okay first of all
assault weapon is a
nebulous term that means different
things in different places and it's
ill-defined because
i i love that meme of the ruger 10 22
with with with and without a pistol grip
and one's an assault weapon and one's
not
and then you mentioned that hunters use
ar-15s
like the mo i think it's the most
popular rifle used in hunting
yeah i wouldn't say the most popular but
it's very common and you got to look at
the different types of hunting because
hunting is a broad spectrum right right
if you're hunting wild boar
absolutely of course but these these
people clearly don't know don't care and
have to explain it they say shut up
they just want a tribal win and they
want to take power away for you for
themselves or it's worse because they
just want to have
a conversation right they just don't
have a car yeah they just want to have a
conversation right
the story that i get to have is uh when
i went i i went when i went to college
after the military um in my senior year
the parkland shooting happened and so
the
woke chapter of the school decided to
get together and
host a conversation about gun control
the extent of the knowledge of the
people in the room there was me
one other veteran and a guy who had
grown up hunting and who was an avid
hunter
the three of us were the only three who
had ever owned firearms ever bought them
and the other 30 people the extent of
their knowledge
on anything to do with firearms was
watching a single vice versa
so they were they were well-versed and
experienced yeah well the point the
point is like yes oh absolutely right
they knew exactly what they were talking
about and the problem that you have
there is
we can look at each other as equals as
people but we do not have equal
information
we do not know you don't when someone
thinks that they deserve a position at
the table when they're not even
capable of being literate on the subject
so
why are we debating are you saying
service guarantees citizenship
i am reading that book for the first
time because
i've mentioned it i'm i'm reading i'm
reading starship troopers for the first
time right now well yeah
it's a huge problem especially for me
because i i got uh
there's a photo of me that um mike feedy
took so he came out he's the bmx guy
from the vlogs and he came out with us
and as i was carrying the barrett which
is a ridiculously large and heavy gun i
had this you know grin let's put it that
way it was a grin it was a grin
i'd call it something more but we don't
swear we don't so we don't do that here
and so uh
no i swear swear grin it's a you know
anyway uh somebody commented tim's
tim's journey from i'm in favor of some
reasonable gun control to to
absolutist is the greatest character arc
ever or something like that and i was
like it's a good point
and the issue was i lived in a city i
was interested in hearing the the
thoughts and opinions of those who who
owned guns
but having never fought uh having well i
did fire one but
having not owned any or gone through the
process to own any
or learned anything about different
types of ammunition or weapons i was
like
i think a conversation makes sense
there's some things we can do
and then when the riots broke out
someone tried to break into my house
i'll tell you this
someone tried to break into my house and
then they made this really really
hilarious meme
where it was like uh you know you know
the sheba's that are all like weak and
pathetic
yeah yeah and it was it was like tim in
2019 and it was the weak sad one saying
help someone's trying to break into my
house call 9-1-1
and then it was like tim poole 2020 and
it's like the big rip dog carrying a
bunch of guns and he's like you get what
you deserve
so so after someone tried breaking in i
uh
the cop told me he's like he i'll
paraphrase
he basically said get a gun and he said
if it were me here's what i'd do
so i went to a local police station and
i said what's the process for new jersey
and they gave me information that was
bad
and then i went online and looked it up
and i got information that was bad
and then i was like i don't have time
for this like i'm working
you know crazy hours and everything you
know so i just lost track of things
then when the riots kicked up i was like
i have no choice
and the mistake i made was i should have
went to the gun shop first they want to
sell me the gun
they need to make sure i can get the
paperwork i think it took me like two
months
to finally be able to go and pick up the
equipment and you know
we were talking earlier in the show
about stephen crowder sending me the sig
m400
the reason i couldn't get it for a year
i could have got it sooner
but i couldn't get it because they sent
it to new jersey which has insane laws
which made it very difficult the gun had
been modified in several ways before i
could pick it up
before they could ship it out to any
other store and so there was a process
and it fell through and i'm like i don't
have time to deal with this it was it
was
they put all these road blocks in the
way to make sure you you basically can't
do it
well now we're basically in west
virginia and so they just snap their
fingers and here you go that's what
that's what constitutional carry is like
so that was new jersey you're moving
from yeah leaving new jersey yeah and so
you couldn't own the firearm in its
current state because of
how because of new jersey law yep and so
make no sense which which essentially
what you're saying is that new jersey
law
new new jersey law says that you are
legal if you are incapable and you are
illegal if you are capable
yeah i mean yeah yep so that means they
don't trust you and that means it's
malice
i just i just think it was funny so when
we were filming the vlog and i'm at the
uh the gun shop picking up the cigar 400
finally gets shipped in
and uh one of the guys at the shop so i
do the background check i do
knicks and i was they were researching
me so it's a little bit longer but it
was like 15 minutes
and then he says congratulations you
know uncle sam says you're allowed to
have the gun
and i was like oh oh thank you uncle sam
for allowing me to exercise my
inalienable right
that's where we're currently at it's a
rifle it's it's it's crazy because these
leftists
that there's there's a lot of ignorant
ones but the people who work for these
non-profits the people who are writing
policy
they know that an ar-15 is one pull the
trigger one bullet comes out they know
there's no
way that they've spent 10 15 20 years
advocating to ban guns and they've not
actually ever google searched any of
them
they know they're lying they know they
use assault weapon to scare people
yeah there's a classic argument that
says something like there's no such
thing as an assault weapon and here's a
little known industry secret
nobody likes no no a fully automatic
weapon is 100 a hobbyist tool with the
exception of very specific military
applications
if you're not using a belt fed machine
gun or a submachine gun like a fully
automatic ar-15 has almost no value yeah
we we've talked about it quite a bit on
the show we i remember who it was maybe
it was jim was it
was it jimmy jim hansen jim hansen
mentioning uh maybe it was maybe
somebody else uh in vietnam it was spray
and pray
and so they just waste so much ammo and
they're like we can't do this it's
ineffective
so they wanted to make people use
semi-auto it's more
you know precise well yeah so you think
about body mechanics like when i'm
every individual pull the trigger you
look at go look at like a three gun
competition and go look at someone who's
really good at it
that guy shoots really fast almost it
almost looks like he's shooting fully
automatic
the fact is that he's doing is each with
each pull the trigger
he is making a conscious decision to
pull that trigger and put that bullet
as best as he can where he wants it so
if i'm just holding the trigger and
holding it and swinging my gun around
like a hose
i'm probably not going to hit my target
i think if anybody's played a game like
you play the division
i played the first one for about a week
division was awesome uh division two was
pretty
good but i really liked the first one
and then i i stopped playing i don't
play many video games
but you in in that game it's actually
pretty great because you can get
like real guns you know and i always
played i always use
like my favorite gun to use in the game
was the was the m1 or
m1a or whatever because for that reason
a lot of people i know would like to use
you know submachine guns or whatever in
the game like to relate to video games
called the division
but then you're you're it's praying
praying you're like just hoping your
your accuracy will be high enough
whereas the way i play is just like one
one one you know
yeah you look at a game like call of
duty and your character can
take an m4 concept and hold it on a
decent circle
um for just the whole magazine like
that's right it's not
really i mean you can do that you
technically can
but it's just not not not only is it not
efficient but it's
it's sort of like is it really video
games that are driving the culture
which is why i am i cannot wait until
some one of these big companies comes
out
and they make a game where you're using
the guns like people do in the military
so you're running around with your m4
and it's on single shot yeah because
that's exactly how you're going to do it
and so yeah given the whole fully
automatic mechanic is a little bit more
i don't know video game normal it's doom
i guess you can
paraphrase halo i just man i remember
growing up
and i'm watching a movie and you know my
dad's sitting there
and my dad always would always you know
comment and say things and predict
things
and then there's i can't remember what
movie it was i'm a little kid and then
like the bad guy sneaks into the room
and then my dad goes who silence her and
then the guy pulls out a gun and goes
yep and like people grow up believing
that stuff's real yeah i mean
go watch the movie django unchained and
in one of the late season or late
episode or late
scenes of the movie the main character
shoots another person at one angle and
he flies the other way fly a different
direction that's
quentin being awesome yes yes and and
that was funny
we hope to trust that it's quentin
tarantino making fun of his own not
taking his work too seriously
but the problem is that it was great
it's great right but now now people will
watch movies
like and they will legitimately think
that's how it works and then they ban
things based on the movies yeah what's
the what is that gelman amnesia effect
for you're reading the news you read an
article that you are an expert in and
you realize it's all bunk you turn the
page and then you're like huh
like it's the same thing with firearms
like if you're a doctor or a nurse you
know that the nurse tv shows are not
really that accurate but then you so
when you watch ncis it's not the same a
department of diagnostics you watch
house
i didn't i succeeded episodes yeah it
was basically i guess the premise of
house was like
sherlock holmes as a doctor or something
and so he gets a mystery
i mean people believe this stuff like i
was reading a story about how
uh people would go to the doctor with
and they would ask the doctor like
what's wrong with me i'm sick
and when they'd be like well we're not
entirely sure we'll give you a scan
they'd be like can you send me to
diagnostics they'd be like what
what be like like dr house they'd be
like that's not real that's a tv
show yeah there's no like head doctor to
just break into your home and steal your
your
your bath soap to try and figure out if
it's got a chemical in it like that's
what they did in the show
like the doctors would literally break
into the person's house and then like
take their drano and be like look what
we found
this is what's killing him you know what
man
i don't know how you solve for that
problem because you're allowed to have
tv shows
but people believe tv and movies are
real too much
yeah i would never want to have like an
enforcement of accuracy committee
right i mean you there's there's a kind
of a trope that goes about in in
in the military that some people have
lost their jobs because they went to
advise
uh entertainment and they were too
accurate there's
their stories what's what's the
legitimate reason for making suppressors
nfa items for those that aren't familiar
it's like you gotta file a tax it takes
like nine months you get your
fingerprints it's very difficult to buy
yeah there is a there is a there is a
burden entry for
owning a suppressor which is an item
that makes it safer to shoot the firearm
yeah it's just insane yeah what it what
does it do it protects hearing damage
now if you're going to if you're going
to uh universalize healthcare
and you you're going to get more people
with hearing damage
okay so silencers aren't real the id the
term silencer
is just a colloquial term right in the
in what and and
the there was a long time when people
referred to them as silencer
right now people are using the term
suppressor more often
and i think some of that is as an as an
attempt to better
translate what the object does that's
still loud there's still a lot
the bullet passes or breaks the sound if
the bullet breaks the sound barrier
you're still getting the sonic crack and
that's probably that's what's going to
hurt the most
yeah so yes when i when you shoot a
firearm that has a suppressor on you're
probably wearing ear protection as well
yeah
yeah i've i've uh i've fired a weapon
with suppressor it's still loud
the recoil was better and it wasn't as
loud but it's like
people could hear it probably a mile
away i mean if you know what it sounds
like yeah
you actually know what it sounds like
but you were talking about events with
people in the riots
where someone is launching fireworks
okay but someone is shooting a gun
and they think it's fireworks well so so
in these riots it's
it's never it's almost never fireworks
sometimes people will throw fireworks
but uh
in my experience it's more often that
someone's shooting a gun
and then you get really dumb journalists
being like zones like fireworks there
was a tactic in minneapolis where they
were activists were firing whatever they
were we're firing
legitimately firing mortar fireworks at
buildings and people but those are very
different
booms right they are so they are
you know you ever see fire you know
firecrackers like you get the right
package you're like
cats yeah is that what they're called uh
are they no those are black cats are
they
maybe i think they are yeah yeah they're
like the little red and white ones yeah
and you let them go pop
and i've and actually we had some
recently we were uh
yeah we had some recently we just popped
them off in the parking lot or whatever
but uh journalists for some reason think
that people just carry those around with
them in cities
especially in like you know crime-ridden
areas during riots yeah you can't buy
them in minneapolis which means you have
to go to a different state to get them
or or it's a gun or people are going pop
pop pop and they're like just fireworks
just you know mine
whatever it's fine yeah again their
their their information
is being given to them is bad let's
let's get a little a little apocalyptic
i suppose so
you know we're talking about guns the
right to keep in bear and all this stuff
can we just go post apocalyptic
post-apocalyptic we're not there yet
okay okay we got the store for the daily
mail gas prices climbed to seven
year high of three dollars and four
cents a gallon despite colonial pipeline
reopening after dark side hack
all right so this is what i don't
understand they said it was panic buying
people are just panic buying you know
and that's why there's no gas in dc
and much of these places and then we
found out that
the friday the hack happened within
three hours they paid the ransom to re
to
to shut it down so why did they shut
down the pipeline
why was supply threatened if they paid
the ransom did they lie to the
government
which resulted in bad information and a
panic
did they disrupt supply which led to
panic and then an actual shortage some
doesn't
some doesn't add up this is the kind of
stuff that's going to exacerbate
inflation and
it's already getting crazy man i mean
you know what we
we we went to the restaurant after after
shooting and we waited like two hours
for food because they had no staff
wow yep and it was it was miserable
i mean i don't want to be mean to the
restaurant they were trying and i
respect them
for working like two people on staff for
this restaurant because nobody wants to
work
now gas prices are super high so here's
here's what we're talking about so we're
sitting there we thought it was gonna be
45 minutes
you know you go in you order you get the
food you leave and then at like two
hours i'm like okay we're gonna get up
and go and then the food finally comes
out
and i was like here's what happens the
prices are skyrocketing and people are
getting unemployment benefits
they're getting 16 bucks an hour not to
work now joe biden saying he's gonna do
the 300
tax credit for you know up for every kid
so now families can get like three grand
for their kids so now you got people who
just don't want to work
so now you got one line cook at your
restaurant
now you got all these people come in and
he's going crazy trying to fill these
orders and eventually he just stops and
says
for 15 bucks an hour no way i'm done
now you got no cook now you got no
restaurant nope
apocalypse this kind of shortage is
something that my parents have been
concerned about for
the entire time i've known them this is
something that my grandparents were
concerned about my grandparents were
stockpiling in the mountains in new
mexico to make sure that they were
safe if and when there was for example a
trucker strike they were very concerned
about like the cuban missile crisis i
think this was around that time
and this is something that i think that
modern people don't take seriously
anymore
and i think that there is like this
derogatory term we're called preppers
you don't want to be a prepper a prepper
is some old redneck dude who just is
everybody thinks they're crazy because
they think the end of the world is
coming well like tim
says what if it rains sometimes
sometimes it rains that's what i think
there's a difference between you know a
prepper and what we would do
for instance right but there is like
this there's this the stigma
to just be prepared and people call it
reactionary which i was telling you
earlier that
i don't understand how can you be
reactionary when something hasn't
happened yet you're trying to think
ahead
yes i don't see that as being an issue
yeah when did self-sufficiency become
a pejorative right when the rich people
want to make sure they can get gas and
supplies before you
and then you'll get news outlets saying
we should we shouldn't report on this
because then people will panic
and then and then what they do is they
whisper to their family make sure you go
buying gas right now
yeah like would that be the same thing
as uh as uh
saying you shouldn't get you you don't
need to wear a mask you don't need to go
and buy one so we can stockpile a bunch
of them
and now we're gonna make it necessary so
we're gonna we're gonna make sure it
hits our warehouse
so that we can charge you for it not
them that's exactly what i'm saying
so when when the colonial pipeline stuff
happens and they're like
there's no supply shortage and then
we're watching videos of cars lined up
in gas stations shutting down and it's
like
what are you talking about oh no no we
meant in terms of the national
supply yeah well no one's asking about
that they're asking about their local
gas stations
yeah and meanwhile these journalists are
are whispering the security people are
whispering
telling their friends and their family
to go stock up while you still can yeah
go buy your toilet paper before it's too
late
yeah the i got mine philosophy you know
you can change it you can make you can
ruin the system after i got mine
you can you can as long as i have and
that that is a
i mean humans are selfish creatures to
some extent right oh for sure
wild animals man especially when panic
takes hold you know
so now i'm wondering if this is uh well
i guess it doesn't matter if it's panic
what matters is prices are going up
there's a global shortage now i love
this
they were what did they say first
there's no inflation problem don't worry
a week later okay there's inflation what
should we do about it now bloomberg
publishes a story saying there's a
global supply shortage of basically
everything
so what's happening is a combination of
things you shut down the economy
people stopped working they leave their
jobs you can't just find people again
like a steel mill isn't just going to be
like okay let's just teleport someone
here to start making this deal again
a lot of these people left moved a lot
of people moved out of new york half a
million people move out of new york what
do you do to fill those jobs
you can't do anything so now they can't
just restart the economy the problem is
biden is also just printing money and
dishing it out to everybody firing the
money guns
so people don't need to go back to work
if you don't make stuff there's no stuff
so now these businesses are struggling
to get the stuff they need to make new
stuff
and then people can't buy it so what
happens two people
chop at you know the hot dog stand the
guy's got one hot dog left what
what do you get you get a bidding war
you get i'll give you five bucks for
i'll give you six seven eight nine ten
fifteen i'm not spending 50 bucks on hot
dog now hot dog costs 15 bucks
everybody's going to be fighting over
these materials and
one of the things that we're seeing
according to bloomberg is that a lot of
businesses
are are buying as much raw material as
possible
and then all of a sudden everything's
sold out they're hoarding it basically
panic buying that's that's that's
ridiculous that's what they did
in uh there's a canadian ad for during
world war one where they were like do
not hoard flower have you guys ever seen
that it's like a comic book
what did you just buy i bought about 250
pounds of flour
why because uh because i'm not panicking
i'm pretty sure that depending i'm about
eight months ahead of the curve when
does it doesn't expire
yeah like two years a year and a half
but we can freeze it too you're gonna
eat 250 pounds of flour
we go through about five pounds a week
oh so ian engages in needing
a stress reliever is this what i need it
makes a lot of bread gluten
yeah i made bread a cup two breads in
the last two days
it makes a lot of bread and then i was
pouring maple syrup on it
and then it soaks through the bread then
you mop it up and it's like a french
toast without having to cook it you
gotta get off all that sugar
hey you're the you're the guy who's
ragging sugar according to vladimir
putin
what you gotta do is learn to cook he
was giving a talk to a bunch of like
college students and they were like what
should we
vlad what should i do as a man a russian
man and he's like learn how to cook and
they all laugh and like no really what
should i do and he was like learn how to
cook
because when the apocalypse comes and
you're and you're eating rabbit
learn how to cook it's going to take two
hours at the store then it's gonna be
four hours then it's gonna be closed i'm
so thankful that my family taught me how
to cook as a kid yes it's like
and it was just because i come from a
culinary family
shout out to mom speaking of hunting for
food we let bucko out he's like an
outside cat
he caught a baby rabbit he brought it
for us and he started eating it
and he got blood on the porch and i'm
like dude you're getting stains what are
you doing
and then he said he just looked at me
and i'm like okay dude
and then he went off and hunting again
he's loving it but uh
you know it's funny to talk about the
cat doing these things but he's got the
right idea man
i think people need to get back to some
of those basic survival skills i'm not
saying people should go and eat cicadas
out of the ground that's insane
but i think it's important that people
learn how to do some basic stuff go
camping remember when the boy scouts
were all about like
i don't know just being a well-rounded
person
and learning how to be responsible and
now it's just weird
cult diversity oh yeah yeah the origin
of boy scouts is
like a pretty cool tale of heroism and
now it's it's it's
nothing but like american mediocrity
what is that
what's the origin of it it was if i'm
not mistaken it was a um
it was a war veteran i think from world
war one i'm pretty sure as a world war
one veteran who basically came back to
the united states
and wanted to provide a program for
young men
young boys to become better people
through
individual challenges i love it right so
like it's the whole
idea of the merit badges is so that the
kids can get some sort
the young boys can learn some sort of
concept of
forward thinking and planning so i want
to get this achievement
this is what i have to do to
accomplishment i can't just that's cool
buy it it's like a video game yeah i
mean it is a proto video game
yeah it's very much so a proto video
well anyway you're mentioning
uh something about you know don't hoard
flower yeah
what was that was that i cut you off oh
uh in in canada in world war one they
had like
national like do not hoard flower it's a
felony i don't know if it was what they
called it but they would come to your
house and arrest you and there's a
picture of cops
walking by the house and people inside
hiding their flowers that sounds common
because as the as the food starts to
disappear they're going to tell you
don't hoard
i mean yeah does anybody else want to
laugh at that it can a ca a command
economy which is always supposed to
eliminate scarcity automatically
immediately produces people are dumb
i mean it's a self-correcting problem
though it's like okay let the command
economy do the thing and we're going to
go be self-sufficient over here
well hold on i hear you 100 million dead
it's not i'm not saying it's not a
tragedy it's terrible yeah i mean
these communist countries did
technically correct themselves by
collapsing into themselves
failing yes but they were able to
just murder their way into maintaining
power for for a century
because the people of capacity whether
it's moral or capability either left the
country or were killed
yeah i mean that's that's the big
problem could you imagine you know
a an able-bodied man of good moral
standing in principle
living in an urban center and then
freaking out because of rides and maybe
i want to live here and then leaving or
somebody who maybe lives in an area like
that planning on leaving am i are you
saying i'm able-bodied
i'm talking about me and you actually
okay i'm joking i'm joking yeah because
we were in the philly area and i was
like we shouldn't be here but my
uh you know all right making fun of
myself be over with
what i'm what i what i think when we
leave these areas
we voted yeah and we advocated and we we
talked
and the community votes for
self-immolation and i don't want to be a
part of that
yeah i'm not interested in saving the
city it's it's it that but that's the
whole like that's
when you look at the second amendment
there's two
ways that it's often interpreted from
the positive side so
we're going to make the assumption that
those who are arguing for gun control
either disdain or don't care about the
second amendment
but now you have the second amendment
people who defend it on sort of
tribalism it's a little bit more
political
and then you have people who understand
the principle of it so for me
you know you think about it simply the
fact that people
over 200 years ago wrote on a piece of
paper the second amendment you know
the right to sh right now to write known
bear arms whatever the second amendment
the fact that they put that on paper
doesn't really mean anything for me the
what really means because that paper is
not going to defend me against a
malicious actor
the fact is that that paper is there to
inform the american people that it's
like
it is your god-given right it is a human
right not a civil right
to own a firearm yep it's a human right
and then and so that sounds
like it sounds sort of well you know the
term human right is thrown around a lot
today
why is it a human right the right to
self-defense is
is something that you have because
you're a human whether or not you're you
believe it's because of imago dei and
you're coming from the christian
heritage or you think about human
equality
if you believe in human equality at all
you would never
in any way argue for one group of people
to go to another group of people and
disarm them
because now they're not equal so since
when does second amendment not include
swords
i mean i know there are places where you
can't own swords but yeah
yeah it's interesting when you look at
some states where they ban basically
every
every version of a weapon in any
capacity except for guns because second
amendment
and i'm like it says to keep and bear
arms yeah you can like there's places
where you can't own a
you cannot carry brass knuckles but you
can carry a six-shooter
i think that's ridiculous as as if the
founding fathers
at that time only used muskets
yeah i mean there's tons of weapons they
had knives they had bows and arrows
big knives cannons yes well we have the
american bowie knife
classic example i think one of the
biggest mistakes that has been made over
the generate
over the past you know 100 plus years or
whatever is that even 2a
advocates have fallen into the trap of
arguing only on behalf of guns
as if the founding fathers literally
only had muzzle loading muskets and
nothing else i'm pretty sure that keep
in bear arms
they carried knives with them and they
probably didn't consider someone come
and take them away
now you get states that are like your
knives are gone your batons are gone you
can't carry a baseball bat unless you
also have a baseball and can prove
you're going to a baseball game
you can't carry a sock full of quarters
you can't do that
but a gun okay second amendment
possession is considered intent
of what baseball battle off quarters you
owning a firearm is perceived as you
wanting to do violence on somebody
that's this i'm just i'm just saying i
think our second amendment includes any
weapon
i agree with you absolutely but there's
tons of places that have banned swords
yeah they're they okay let's not say
they've been they've banned
swords they've infringed upon your human
rights yeah
you know absolutely let's not say that
they've banned swords they haven't
banned swords they are
saying that we will do violence against
you if you own something that can do
violence
so in in that capacity i'm just saying
it's great that we they they built this
shield
in written word that protected us for a
good you know a couple hundred years
we'd be worse off without the
constitution no doubt but at this point
imagine look at it this way there is a
great giant dragon beast
that is government authoritarianism and
it's been breathing fire on the
noble hero who's holding up the
constitution as a shield
and eventually that shield starts
burning through and
long enough period of time of sustained
government authoritarianism and we start
losing our rights
interestingly we have this supreme court
case
so scotus rules police cannot search
homes without warrants in the name of
community caretaking
this is unanimous nine to zero so that's
promising even the liberal justices were
like a cop can't go into your house
without a warrant and take all your guns
because they think you're you're ill or
something it's a good sign
but it's it's it's crazy to me that the
argument is is
getting close to the red flag law stuff
and a lot of people
i guess right now are like oh of course
they can't have you know
they can't without a warrant but what
they've been actively trying to do is
get a warrant claiming that you're
unwell and then violating your rights
yeah disarming you through a subversive
means
and it's it like in in i think it's
according to the geneva convention
disarming a population is considered an
act of war
wow as it should be i think i believe
that somewhere it's uh in that
either is that or it's carl von
klausowitz but we haven't had a von
klossowitz in a while
so you might know this but what
percentage of the time
is a genocide preceded by removing guns
from the general population because i
was able to come up with more than one
example to send to someone i was arguing
with
yeah i wouldn't say it's a hundred
percent but it's basically a hundred
percent yeah i mean it's it's
because they are one and the same and
this is how you think about tyranny
so we often think or the the thing is
oftentimes said something like
well if you disarm a population then
then then you will have genocide or then
you'll have some sort of massive
glo you know massive tragedy con
horrible authoritarian argument
and so we use it as this argument of
like the one begets the other
i don't think that's the right way to
think about it the rather is
the act of the act of um
is that i'm sorry i don't think it's the
right way to think about it because it
creates an opportunity for someone to
say we won't do it this time
you know we won't okay we'll take away
your guns but we won't genocide you this
time like that's
you're essentially holding on the you're
holding your entirety of your existence
and your hope on the fact that they
won't do something
whereas what i would i think the better
way to think about it is the act of
taking the firearms away from somebody
is wrong in the exact same way as it is
to target a population in that way
well one doesn't get the other they are
they fall in the same vein
you need to understand that if the earth
is to join the galactic federation
we can't have a bunch of crazies with
guns we're going to shoot the aliens
when they show up so
they got to disarm us for the sake of
the of the galactic federation right
um your condescension is coming through
wow no i'm just being ridiculous no i'm
just kidding there's
what it is it's a bunch of elites who
would lie to the general public
to protect themselves and their family
they would tell you there's no gas
shortage so they can go buy gas before
you can
they would tell you that everything's
fine there's tons of toilet paper so
they can buy it up before you can
they would buy a bunch of stock while
serving in congress
and then pass regulations on these
companies which benefit their stock
decisions
their trading decisions and they would
come out and say you can't own weapons
because safety now for me i've got five
armed guards around me at all time paid
for by your tax dollars
yeah and we use guns for you we saw this
last year the exact same people that
were arguing to defund the police
spent millions of dollars making sure
they had very armed people protecting
their house and we
and and it's like and you can't look at
that and say oh that's funny you should
look at that and go like
appalled by that the the even the people
who voted for
we we do man i mean the people who watch
a show like this
um probably most conservatives we we are
appalled by that but there is a
large faction in this country of
extremely ignorant tribal individuals
who have no idea what's going on um i
posted this on facebook i said what
happened all those people who used to
come in my mentions and just like
promote joe biden and rag about trump
they're all gone
well gone you know why because they
never cared about biden no then because
you what bought guns now you're a bad
now you're a bad conservative man
no back during the election all of these
people i knew who cared nothing for
politics never did
all of a sudden we're like oh by then we
had to vote for biden we must do it
and then binding gets elected and
they're gone they no longer care about
trump they don't
care about biden they don't care about
politics now they post about stupid
nonsense
and i'm like i thought what about all
those things you were so what happens is
these people now
have voted for a man who is by like
every objective metric failing
and i love these op-eds where they're
like biden's had the best hundred days
of any president ever and i'm like yeah
if your head's in the toilet you're not
paying attention
but a lot of people a lot of these
people just walked away anyway so now
things are getting worse
and too many of these people vote for
trash laws and leave
us worse off for it i don't know how you
solve for that
unless like starship troopers or
whatever i don't know uh in order to in
order to vote you must prove
or prove ownership of a firearm yeah
i mean then you'd at least have skin in
the game it's meant to be facetious but
it does get the point across mandatory
gun ownership
i mean you you we don't the problem with
containing something a vote like this is
not it's not a very complicated problem
it's that
who gets to choose right this is
essentially the question of
all power like thank you who gets to
choose right so if you make it
you know one of the arguments that comes
up is something like
uh we don't want people who are mentally
thankfully for the the supreme court
case that you were talking about we
don't want we want to make sure at least
to some extent people of certain mental
issues
don't own firearms right we kind of want
to there's this sort of it's
let's take the question honestly and
look at it that way yes that's true
who gets to choose big question it's
it's it is an interesting point because
i've brought up uh several times
the second amendment doesn't say the
right to keep in bear arms should not be
infringed unless you're mentally ill
yeah i know and it is a problem like it
is a legitimate mental problem or do you
say like you you were arguing about
if you do the time if you pay your debt
to society you should have your rights
restored
so a good point was meant to be though
that the constitution does allow for
rights to be
restricted uh after after or only
through due process
only through due process so and mental
deficiency i believe
through due process then all right i
understand that argument that makes
sense to me
yeah so if if you know i own a bunch of
guns and then there's a claim filed
against my mental health
and we go and there's a legal process
and then after determining i'm unwell
then they come and take everything that
makes sense to me
i'm still worried about it because
mental health is
not objective it's an ambiguous category
in some ways it is viewed as an
ambiguous category oh yeah
so some guy can just be like i was
looking at ian and he is crazy
my professional experience is that he is
crazy and dangerous
and then the judge is like i agree
ceases guns anyone that's got like a
medical marijuana card for stress or any
kind of psychological issue could then
be deemed like
unwell and unfit to hold a gun that's
cool oh yeah you can't you can't you
can't buy a gun if you smoke pie right
well you're not supposed to you so can
and should are different
um there isn't but there is a question
on the 4473 that asks are you currently
or are you consuming illegal substances
and it's not and the 4473 is a federal
document
and straight up if you smoke pot you
can't buy it so technically speaking if
you
you are committing a very big crime if
you are currently consuming
marijuana not like smoking it at the gun
shop
i mean but not not technically literally
your federal government literally says
you are committing crime if you consume
these things
under biden did it yeah it's freaking
crazy man schedule one narcotic
marijuana
that makes no sense right yeah there's a
there's a parallel that's kind of coming
through in
in the world and this is kind of begging
the question but there's a joke
who won the war on drugs weed won the
war on drugs
right it's kind of a humor and how did
weed win the war on drugs mass
non-compliance
yeah which was is you could also look at
that in a sort of philosophical sense it
was self-reliance
well the government's not gonna let me
have my weed so i'm gonna get it myself
the government's not gonna allow me to
protect my family so i'm gonna figure
out myself
it's time to end the war on guns
absolutely yeah
but how do you do it i mean we a whole
and for us we're doing it through
culture we're doing it through
going out and doing things we have our
publications and what do we get for it
we get pulled off of newsstands really
yep we've
we've had our magazine anything gun
related has been pulled off of
newsstands no one no one talked about it
you didn't see a giant new york times
post
when google bans gundam wing because
it's got gun in the name
you know they really don't like guns but
how are we being self-reliant here's a
good example
if you own a gun store give us a call
we'll stock it in your
on your shelf right there you go if you
own a gun store if you own an ffl
we you get a hold of us you can get a
hold of us through our website and we
will
we have a program to stock our magazines
because we've got four different
magazines concealment
which is urban smaller firearms all
about safety
concealed carry making sure you're doing
things the right way being good at it
and then you've got recoil which is the
main magazine this is sort of the big
news gun industry things maybe it's
someone came out with something really
innovative
or you know we there's a there's an
advocate well we did um
montgomery we put yeah so he's you know
monster is doing something great there's
uh
chris chang is doing something great
with aapi go
so we are grabbing we have those two
magazines then we have off grid which is
much more focused on skills
survival um and it has it
and and i think of the the advantage
that off-grid has it has a lot of things
about doing
right so it's not just about gear
because a lot of a lot of
um survival a lot of the negativity that
comes from survivalist
groups or preppers is they're just about
buying stuff it's the classic
you know heavily unfit person with a
bunch of stuff
is not going to survive the apocalypse
right yeah and then the last one we have
is carnivore which is all about
high-end field-to-table consumption
meat consumption yep so i i i
uh loathe to think about what's gonna
happen to these cities in the event that
there's like an actual shutdown
the water shuts off people are gonna
start dying dehydration they'll be
drinking blood in a day
yeah you'll have i mean historically
speaking you'll have a very short period
of very very ugly violence and then
you'll have a very long period of
probable starvation
oh you know people fleeing like crazy in
random directions
well and the solution is actually in
itself and i think the solution to this
one is not just buying a bunch of stuff
it's actually community
it's i mean the term community is thrown
around a lot publicly right now
but the again the antidote to this
classic idea of a guy in a basement with
a bunch of bullets and a bunch of
food is that he's going to die alone why
is what is what is prison
it is living in a box for 30 years you
know
there's not it's it's taking your life
away life is time
so survival real survival when you're
talking about things like this
is actually 100 based on community
social interaction with people who you
actually trust that you've been a lot
you've been
you've been you can you can have them to
protect you from making mistakes that
you would otherwise not know
right so someone who knows water someone
who knows ecology someone who knows hey
don't eat those plants
that's a simple form of it a more
complicated one is
you're desperate we know each other we
take care of each other we're not
waiting for the government to come and
save us
it's actually quite remarkable how
people in
cities mostly but basically everybody is
extremely detached from the basic
requirements of survival yeah
i mean maslov's hierarchy of needs yeah
right it's not
it's not an ultimatum but
people you take a person in the city and
you put them in the woods
it's just not going to go well sure
because they have no reason to be
adapted to the woods if you live in an
urban environment you're all life you're
never going to need to adapt the
abilities to do that
it's a it's a luxury you will need to
adapt the abilities it's
likely at some point in your life you
will need to understand basic survival
even if you live in a city
it's just that and they're immediate
they don't
they that life has been kind to them to
the extent that they've never been
thrust in a situation like that sure
that's absolutely true but
we i still want to return to the idea
like self-sufficiency
is a good thing right right so it's not
you know when you have a neighborhood
like say you know you live in a condo
and you know your neighbors
it's not a it's not a bad thing to know
your neighbors and being like oh
i know such and such as a diabetic and i
can help them to i can help take care of
them this way
it doesn't mean you're kicking down
their doors and saying here take the
insulin
right but it's good people people
realize how brutal it'll get
if there's actual like power outages or
uh
like rolling blackouts even let alone if
the water shuts off or the electricity
goes out for an extended period of time
people people who are diabetic you got
to refrigerate that insulin that's a
huge problem for just
storms going on they gotta have
generators usually to make sure the
fridges keep running
but there's a lot of other things too
people's medications will spoil if
you've got antibiotics in the fridge
they're gone vaccines go bad very very
quickly
without electricity yeah so hey bring it
on go to tune burger let's turn off all
the fossil fuel power plants and then
see how long humans last because they
will
they will start tearing each other's
throats throats out as it gets bad
or they'll just build a pipeline and not
tell you about it
pipeline a pipeline yeah you know if you
if you tell people they can't have
something and they need it they'll
figure out a way
look one of the big themes of this is
that they're going to tell you oh no
don't go buy this
then they go rush out and buy it sure
they're coming out saying like
go the water is going to rise 20 feet
i'll take that beachfront condo on miami
beach
how much is that water's rising i don't
care about that
no sure ammunition prices are high right
now so if you're hoarding ammunition
it's kind of rude
but but the other thing about it too is
how would you just take seriously what
you think you need
it's not more panic buying is a hard
thing to define
and panic buying is what people do when
they feel like they're insufficient with
what they have
it's interesting i mean ian bought a
ridiculous amount of
flour for two years yes
yeah i was surprised it was available
because i'm last july that it wasn't you
could get four or maybe four bags of
flour so why buy so much flour
you know who knows what's coming in two
months i like to look ahead and rest
easy see that's the thing
you know you're hoarding is it someone
being prepared or is it someone
panicking
yeah well it the the there is a good
question to be said there and
or is it are you just a good businessman
and you know you can buy better in bulk
and you're going to be able to store it
and you
are you being proactive after the
apocalypse all the neighbors are going
to be like bread and ian's going to be
like i have the bread and i'll go feed
you
all and he's going to like rip it and
throughout the people and they're going
to cheer for bullets bread for water
dude
feed the masses uh i don't think anyone
would trade you bullets for bread they
only need one i'll let them go hunt and
i'll keep them healthy when they no you
don't understand
they only they only need one oh well
that's a good point you grossly
overestimate the accuracy of most people
that's fair that's fair let's assume
it's point blank
uh they don't need any actually they
just need the weapon you know then most
people would just capitulate
just take whatever you want leave me
alone take my flower take my bread
yeah i'm inspire me but violence is
expensive
yeah yeah i mean it's costly to go to go
do violence on someone is expensive i
mean what about apocalypse though
it still is right so let's go let's take
the metaphorical
um the metaphorical post-apocalyptic
apocalypse situation you have your
little tribe and they have their little
tribe
for you to go attack their tribe to try
to take their stuff
you have to willingly acknowledge that
if you lose it's
final yeah right or you know in order
final it's extremely costly not not just
that but
if i go to ian and i say ian make me
bread and then ian's like
in exchange for what and i say i'll
treat you something then ian's skill and
value as a human being
contributes to the production of bread
if you just go and take the flour
all right well now you got to make the
bread yeah so there's a there's a cost
you lose out
trade is probably safer and easier for
everybody sometimes traders doesn't work
though because
starving person might not have anything
to trade with so a lot of times it's the
language barrier
fortunately we have that going for us in
the us as it's easy to communicate
relatively
you know we don't long-range
communications with the power grid down
would be a little bit more complex like
how do you
how do you tell them that you're not a
that you're not a danger without getting
close
that that might be a challenge you can
kind of just signal you gotta you gotta
create a call i like ham radios
calls yeah bird calls those words maybe
like a
yeah yeah yeah we can go back to classic
bird zones
i i will lose at every time they'll just
be like why is that man sounding like a
chicken
but are we are we is this paranoia i
mean are we just we're talking about all
the stuff but we're seeing the news
we're seeing gas prices and we're like
oh it's the end but maybe nothing
i got this samantha bee on the brain
thing i watched some samantha just
get the depths of it you get out of it
you get out dark you get out you don't
just do something about guns and it was
all these celebrities being like
just do something just do something
about guns
and like they don't know what they're
asking for this is what really bothers
me i literally don't yeah dawned on me
tonight
yeah is the vagueness of it they don't
it's not like
this aspect of this thing they said do
something right yeah they're so vague
okay okay here's what i propose
[Laughter]
i will do something uh repeal all gun
laws yep
and i'll go buy a gun sure yeah you know
um
everyone who owns a gun gets to vote
free guns for everybody yes i don't
know whoa whoa whoa whoa i do not i do
not it's a little light
i think mandatory guns for everybody
okay you have to
when you sign up for the selective
service if you don't have an m3 carl
gustav
holla they want you to sign up for the
select service you should also be
required to go in
fill out the form drop it and be handed
one ar and one handgun
or a rifle and a gun and whatever they
have available some like standard issue
us government garbage weapon it works it
works right i mean
people like to say the swiss did it
right but that's we're talking about
very different countries
swiss i mean there is a sense of
mandatory firearms ownership and
mandatory uh kind of it's not exactly
that but
the swiss are oftentimes used as an
example because everyone owns guns
functionally everyone owns guns but
switzerland also stays out of
you know right interesting country yeah
but you're also looking at like you can
make another argument something like uh
japan
has no firearms and they have very
little firearms violence
they're also an ethnic like a very they
have their their
national state ethno state right yeah
like they don't allow immigrants it's
crazy
they they did it's very very small right
right it's like extremely restrictive
yeah switzerland is also fall small
sorry and don't they also require
military service in switzerland i wanted
to say that's correct i'm not sure
i i don't want to i don't want to say
something that i can't i don't remember
i don't know
well i also look at israel because they
have a similarly small population
everyone there for the most part is
armed and everyone is required to serve
in the military
i don't know what their gun stats are
like but it's probably not bad and
they're constantly under threat
right exactly again all these things are
multifaceted arguments but you take the
example of the samantha bee thing right
just do something you want to look at
what gun control is it's celebration
before success
right because no one ever says hey we
established these new laws
look what the effects are we say just do
something
yay we put this in place never heard
from again here's what we need to focus
on right right now when people complain
about
government and guns it's about
restrictions we need to change it
so i propose the creation of the
department of gun services
so when you're 16 you have to go in for
your manual gun from the
i'm sorry mandatory gun from the
government and the complaints about guns
and government should be
the lines take too long i had to go to
the dgs to get you know an
ar-15 and i had to wait 20 minutes 20
minutes for this gun
it's ridiculous huh i mean when i was a
kid it was 10 minutes you're in you're
out you got your gun your box of ammo
these bureaucrats man that's a serving
the dmv adds like another letter yeah 37
q oh there is conscription in
switzerland by the way
okay yeah just that that's a good one um
yeah and then for your dm
or dgad the department of gun services
like this yeah department of gun service
yeah um
so not everyone knows how to use a
manual and i don't know how to use a
stick shift so now we have to just give
them all automatics
yeah there you go well you know some
people don't have this
the strength so there's a variety of
options no
you'd get some garbage government stock
crap you know you're not going to get
the best of the best but hey hey hey you
know
yeah mandatory gun ownership mandatory
firearms ownership would be an
interesting
example you go in and you're like a
little book explaining like basic gun
operations and you do like a one through
ten check check check
and the guy reviews it and he's like all
right you know here's your your gun and
uh
you can choose between the handgun we
have over here and
you out the forms and then they hand it
to you and you leave and you walk out
and
that terrifies me why i don't know maybe
because i don't know enough about guns
do you want to know why i do the analogy
of the department of gun services yes
when you go to the dmv and there's like
cars everywhere
right and there's a lot of people who
are student drivers
do you like start sweating and no fear
that someone's going to hit you good
point
when you cross a busy street when you're
jaywalking or you're like
there's cars and they could hit me at
any moment not really i see people with
guns all the time and i just don't even
think about it
because people don't typically just run
you over or shoot you or beat you
a a guy could pick up a rock off the
ground and hit you with it you know it
just doesn't happen
sometimes does sometimes they can use
guns i understand when the left are like
yeah but with a gun they're they're
extremely destructive and violent i'm
like it's true
but people also make bombs people do a
lot of things and so
you shouldn't take away someone's right
to self-defense because you're concerned
and you don't want to be responsible for
yourself
i just don't see that as an appropriate
argument i understand the fear
but i cross busy streets all the time
and i've never i don't get hit by cars
you know i if you live in chicago or new
york or l.a you're jaywalking everywhere
and sometimes the cops yell at you and
stupid and for the most part
you'll just see the cars i mean some
people will just
walk and ignore the cars you know why
the cars will break
is this is crazy the cars will actually
stop
to avoid hitting you huh so if you were
at the department of gun services and
someone walked out with a weapon
and they were like let's say let's say
there was like a range
if you walk onto if this is true if you
go if you're on a gun range and you step
onto the range
they scream and shut everything down
they don't
want you to get hurt or if you're at a
range and you like turn around you're
pointing it someone will tackle you
yes normal people are trying to be safe
and don't want to get hurt whether it's
a car or a gun or whatever so gun
services they hand you the gun
in like a locked box and then you have
to carry it home in a locked box
why i don't know not so you don't freak
people out what when there's like 30
people in there i'm not freaked out when
i see a guy in a hummer driving down the
street it's another culture you just got
to get people comfortable with it one
day
i've crossed archer avenue on the south
side of chicago and you got tr
you know big trucks and tractor trailers
or whatever and it's like you just run
across the street
i'm not like oh no the guy's gonna hit
me dude people in my neighborhood
because we had uh we have the freight
trains where you're always getting stuck
by trains by midway it's annoying
the kids in my neighborhood would run
alongside the train and jump on it
that's awesome could you imagine if
there was a guy and he had like a hit
who's like riding around
on a car with a gatling gun and you ran
and jumped on his car and were like
holding his gun that'd be ridiculous i'd
be insane
that's a problem people would like in
the in chicago jump on this range don't
do it it's really really really
dangerous
but people aren't scared they're the
opposite of scared they're brazen
so if somebody walked out with a weapon
people aren't going to care it's the
weirdest thing to me that in new york
you go to grand central and there's like
cops in like full tactical gear with
rifles
people aren't freaking out like a cops
going to shoot anybody
i think ian has a point because when
cars were brand new people were
terrified of them people were scared to
go in them
people were scared to get hit by them so
there maybe there should be like a
transitory time where we're like
accommodating people to everybody having
a gun and there was a time when they
didn't have seat belts
they didn't know they were still
learning the the danger of it all i
don't know what the traffic laws were
like in the beginning probably they
didn't have traffic lights
at first yeah so in in this ideal world
where everyone is required to have a gun
it might require a little bit of
adaptation i think all right fine
whatever but let's do super chats my
friends if you have not done this
smash that like button and take the url
from this youtube video and just share
it across all social media
to help out the show and go to
timcast.com become a member because
we'll have a
bonus segment coming up later today at
the website which you definitely
do not want to miss big news from the
government gets real creepy we'll talk
about it later
but for now we'll do super chats the one
dollar one liner says hey tim nice
promotion of iceland
i can see the brochures come to iceland
there's no ice enjoy the volcanoes it
smells like farts
that's all true have you been there oh
wow so i went to iceland
there was no ice and when i was driving
from
reykjavik to um the the whatever i was
called like the blue water place then
it's like all like
gray rock and you it smells like farts
volcanic rock
there's a lot of water yeah it smells
like farts sulfur salt a lot of sulfur
so what's the blue there's like a blue
water place where the water is blue
something like that wow it's really cool
but it was really hard we couldn't get
in
because it was like booked up like crazy
did it used to be ice like did the
vikings come i mean there's ice
i went to this really cool place it was
cold and it was just like this massive
lake it's beautiful man it's an awesome
place
i heard they called it iceland like the
vikings because they wanted people not
to go there because they wanted it
to keep it for themselves so they told
everyone it's just an ice hell
and no one was apparently a like
garbage hole until they discovered
geothermal energy and everybody was just
like mining coal or something and they
were like we got all this volcanic
activity we could do geothermal and now
they live like kings wow
now abundance of energy you know in in
response to our conversation earlier
about what we're educated by everything
i know about the
the the island of iceland is from the tv
show vikings
there you go i know nothing 21st century
all right
and then there was the secret life of
walter mitty yes also good
kay ross says hey tim i heard they were
putting a 40 tax in taxes on bitcoin for
coins sold
and wondered if anyone knew anything
about this joe biden has proposed a
capital gains tax of like 39.7 percent
so yes that would apply to your bitcoin
massive tax massive tax wow maybe it's
because of bitcoin
kyle buchanan says hvac tech here i
tried ordering an outside unit today the
warehouse said they had
zero and won't have any for 60 days i
doubt they will have any in 60 days
either
the one free man says low gun
regulations equals herd immunity for
violent crime
you don't have to carry but you benefit
from those around you being armed the
same way an unvaccinated person
would benefit from those around them
being vaccinated hey there you go
interesting crime herd immunity
plasma says i bought into bitcoin at 32k
and nearly one uh went net loss
but i am now taking advantage of elon
musk's yeah tweets
and buying more getting ready for the
having in two years when bitcoin will go
to the moon and back
yeah so the having will result in like
bitcoin doubling or more
uh okay i can't read the name here but
this guy says it's a good thing crowder
has made plenty of political connections
over the years hopefully they'll vouch
for him
yeah josh elsa's question for forrest
why don't gun companies name their
weapons in a way that you don't have to
be a nerd to understand i own
a xd mod 2. why
how do they choose their naming
that is a question that i actually don't
know how to answer because
everyone does it differently but the the
it stems out of kind of military
mentality of like
it's it's it's essentially a what do you
call it
it's easy nomenclature it's an m3 carl
gustav we call it a carl g
colloquially but the m3 is so that i can
distinguish it the m16 from the n4
so a lot of companies use these names
these number these letter combinations
to achieve that ends
shorthand right on it's all shorthand
and i mean there are
there's other ways that you can do it
too like you could look at like a ruger
blackhawk it's a revolver
it's not the bk17 the usually the
the number is affiliated with something
to do not with the caliber but
it all has different ways of doing it
and i think it's really just because
it's trendy
yeah right it's just how we chose to do
it so
what are the caliber numbers mean
because like a 22 versus like a 2
3 dramatically different round you know
yeah the caliber typically refers to the
size of the projectile
it typically refers to the size of the
projectile but now you're looking at
so shotguns being different there's is
every it's
it's all referencing the size of the
projectile it's pretty much right is it
the width of the projectile or the
length um
if it should be it should be the
circumference
or the diameter all right we got honey
and absinthe says it is my boo
thang's 30th birthday today will you
wish vincent a happy birthday
we love your show also let me paint a
mural in your house please
uh send us an email to spin the ufo at
gmail.com yes
and happy birthday vincent yeah happy
birthday vincent
i'm willing to bet it's not going in my
house alex oakley says i wanted a super
chat to say that us
usd is officially dying i started a side
job over the weekend where i was asked
if i wanted to be paid in usd bitcoin or
half and half
i chose half and half so excited to get
more bitcoin wow
that's that's not like the cream product
you chose bitcoin right please god
tell me you chose bitcoin half and half
like half
oh i thought you meant like the half and
half cream i did two i was like
kind of guy though that's my problem
that's confused so i strengthen my
weakness
i too am a coffee snack you're getting
paid in buckets of cream yes
yes i got all this green what am i gonna
do just drink it i guess
the grocery store was out it's good eli
m says tim could you call crowder on air
right now and get him to summarize what
has happened
and his way forward no that would be
really awesome though maybe
maybe i i i couldn't do that nah i mean
it probably would be funny
i'm sure he'd be cool with it but it
just can't could you imagine going to
call him like you're on the air and
you're like oh wait what's going on wait
no
some people might just be like no part
of his strike is that he's not supposed
to talk about it
wouldn't you right no i could interview
him oh cool yeah we had alex jones
but they still you know they'll be
paying attention
jennifer rape says great show and guest
as always and gotta shout out my alma
mater sam houston state
for winning the national championship
yesterday edom uh eat em up cats
hey there you go perhaps someone you may
know says hashtag free crowder
there you go
sy coder says walmart is only allowing
vac employees not to wear
masks well i'm not vac and when i get
back from break i'm not wearing a mask i
might get fired
but they're going to get sued if they do
hope i win
i mean how do they tell if people are or
aren't i mean i don't know how they
i think i think they'll ignore you i
don't think they'll say anything i don't
know
whatever hits vape says i work at best
buy they just announced today that if
employees prove they've gotten the
vaccine you don't have to wear a mask
i've had the virus didn't do much at all
to me now i feel forced to
so i can take off the mask yeah
well talk to your doctor
zanzibar says i just joined timcast.com
now where
where do i go to suggest magnus panvidya
get a seat for a show
pro liberty and bottom immunity advocate
what the boogaloo really is
uh well you just did carter joe says tim
have destiny on to discuss the
infrastructure bill and voting bills
and he'd like talking about moral
frameworks uh definitely destiny is
was an excellent guest we we when
destiny was here we actually hung out
for like an hour just talking about
politics and he's a cool dude
disagree with him that's about it but it
disagrees a lot of people
so you know i think that's too much like
fear of the other
i think i think it was great to have him
out here fun guy um
i'm sure people don't like him for a lot
of reasons though joshua ryman says what
if
what used to be a traffic stop that
caught a kidnapper with someone in their
trunk
it's a pass by yeah well there's that
too
rylo says civilian traffic brigade don't
you dare show support for trump or
appear at all conservative
you're going to get bombarded with
tickets and the state will come after
you you see there you go brown bear says
tim when are you going to have
shoe on head on your show when she
accepts the invitation and decides to
come on the show
dolly lance says how can you
continuously assume that the unarmed
civilian won't be violent themselves
that's a good point unarmed civilian
traffic guy might be like i got a gun
yeah how's that work is it a cop cause a
cop well we were just we're trying to
figure that out earlier like a cop is a
civilian according to military no no no
no this new policy is like
you in the car the heck yeah it's a
contradiction of terms though because
are you hired by the state who are you
hired by right not authority side group
i mean they give you a little yellow
light to stick on top of your car
the codification like the codification
of law has a purpose and it's so that we
have a rule
rules by which we understand what we do
and don't do it's not
the greatest tragedy in the american
concept of law is that we have turned
law into a way to make
citizens into servants instead of
realizing that the purpose of law is to
limit the government it is to limit one
group of citizens
from violating the rights of another
group of citizens it's not to make you
safe it's not to make you happy it's not
to make you wealthy the purpose of law
is so that the people can the one group
of people
human beings with the same rights as you
cannot use
the power of the state to violate your
rights
yeah i don't like paid bail because if
the rich people
oh yeah it's meaningless to them they
just buy their way out in in chicago
people illegally park at wrigley field
because they're like a hundred dollar
ticket
it's cheaper than buying a parking space
yeah that's what i'm talking about
all right andrew hulker says i fled the
twin cities for duluth last summer
the number of friends i have at u of m
who have been mugged at gun at
knifepoint just walking through
dinkytown or riding the light rail is
truly insane
well there you go showland report says
livia wisconsin for the last couple of
years never heard a guy from minneapolis
sound so nice and fair
oh thank you there you go mike sullivan
says great guest
south carolina passed house bill 3094
today
eliminates state fees for cwp will now
allow open or concealed carry with a
permit
makes sc a second amendment sanctuary
state great day
yeah it's not constitutional carry you
can look in west virginia you can just
walk around to bear it if you want
yeah people just laugh at you though
because they'd be like we get it we get
your point
there is good luck here too yeah there
is hope in the world like i
one things that i one of the views that
we bring like i like to bring through
recoil is that
it's not all doom and gloom it's not all
doom and gloom and it's not all they're
taking
our guns away young americans don't like
gun control yeah they don't they re
they're turning away from it and whether
they're turning away from it because of
political means whether
it's marxism communism socialism
whatever or
or because they just don't trust the
government they're moving away
on top of that um what is it the
there is ways that we are making
victories they're just not as political
they're not as
pro they're not as polished
theatrical stunts david hogg has a
massive
theater no substance
yeah it's nonsense yeah you know it's
like it's it's he's
you have to prop them up while in the
background people are changing their
opinions about it
look at the last year in gun sales
records massive records and we're not
saying like
because if you look at gun sales
throughout history in the united states
it's kind of a steady climb with little
spikes that kind of level out but it
never really goes up and then down
it goes up and then down a little bit
and then up into you know really
gun sales is a really good performing
stock in the united states um if it was
but you look over the last year it
jumped and plateaued high
and yeah you look at the lines in these
big in these big cities yeah
liberals going lining up outside of gun
shops there was a run fun there was a
funny video
where this guy he at a gun shop he made
a video where he was like
stop coming to my store expecting to buy
a gun for the first time
these liberals keep coming in and they
keep saying can i pay more to get it now
that is
no you can't you voted for this these
are your laws
shut up follow the rules because it's
probably hilarious
to have like your 50th guy come in and
be like i'd like to buy that gun okay
fill out the form
okay can i get it no you're on a delay
list we come back in five days we'll
call you
can i pay more no you can't pay more
you're being background check shut up
and go home
they get all mad about it yeah i mean if
you want to have the conversation what
universal background checks already in
place stop talking about it
right right right sergeant buck says
just joined as a member
if you want a modern military shooter
that handles firearms well i recommend
insurgency sandstorm
the division 2 is great but it becomes
but it's become destiny 2 with cover
i completely agree yeah eric rodriguez
says what are y'all's opinions on
bullpup rifles
i personally prefer them especially as a
left left-handed person
love the show keep it the great work can
i not answer
it it's no i can't um i have never
i do not have a lot a lot of experience
with both rifles what is it in compared
to
a you know like an ar-15 yeah what does
it mean bullpup
bullpup rifle this is the muzzle this is
the the the buttstock right
if my hand is in front of the magazine
the trigger is in front of the magazine
so it goes barrel
trigger magazine which allows me to get
a longer barrel and a shorter package
that's considered a bullpup when you
take the magazine and you build it
behind
the trigger oh so you look at a like an
ar-15 you've got stock
grip magazine rail
muzzle bullpup takes the magazine and it
in the construction of the rifle and
that gives it better balance so you can
have a longer
muzzle the theory is that you can have
the benefit of a longer muzzle without
an entirely longer firearm and then it
does accomplish that
it's just is the juice worth the squeeze
because you lose something
i think that having the magazine well
in front of the trigger guard and this
is the honest answer is i've been
i've been shooting for so much in the
military with ar-15 style platforms and
and most of the modern military
modern militaries across the world use a
magazine in front um
i'm so used to it switching to a bullpup
would be uncomfortable it'd be it's just
like
it's it is not the same thing it's not
home um but
the one of the advent disadvantages you
get is manipulation of the firearm
tends to be more uncomfortable so when i
have to
load a magazine in here i get to drop
the mag
put a new magazine in the mag well it's
sort of efficient it's all
there but the other one that you start
to see and i think there are quite a few
companies that are actually doing this
very very well um is the triggers in
bullpups were are historically referred
to as being terrible
and so you want a good trigger because
you it adds
accuracy it helps you control the weapon
fire and better
and historically speaking um
firearms with a bullpup design had a
harder time making a better trigger
oh all right all right meridian forest
says hey tim u.s
air force member here i was raised in
north dakota and thankfully got
stationed back in north dakota
recently they voted to ignore a lot of
the federal gun regulations here
i'm not going to say i'm for or against
this because military no thanks to super
chat and thanks for your service
make 1984 fiction again says civil
disobedience and lawsuits let's get a
win in the bag i got kicked off a job
in the authoritarian state of
massachusetts for not wearing a mask
outside
laying pavers on blacktop in 80 degree
weather with no one near me
wow jeez that's a great name
yeah i was thinking that same thing i
have read that book
and it's creepy it's incredible read
1984 if you haven't read that
yeah i got that t-shirt yep
tom uh i think it says tom says second
time super chat i feel stupid i
accidentally just sent you 10 bucks ha
ha here's another 10.
i'm here in washington state zero gas
shortage but i just paid 359 a gallon to
fill up
uh this this uh was it subby sube the
subscribers movie
yes it's getting expensive i heard it
was like nine dollars in some places oh
my gosh
yeah i didn't i couldn't confirm it yeah
i've just been seeing posts i don't know
for sure
in california yeah in some areas it was
absolutely skyrocketing
ray uh rafe purnell says please post or
please post video of ian's gf bread
recipe i need it
gf gluten free your girlfriend's red red
yeah
she's hot um that was quick
i'd have to make a gluten-free recipe
maybe with almond flour but i've noticed
the wheat flour
really handles the yeast and the sugar
in a special way i mix them together
sometimes do like a light gluten with
like an almond flour
if it's gf flower uh bread recipe i
haven't done a gluten-free one in a
while
yeah it's got a good bread i'm done
experiment so i'll look at that rise
kyle lipka says crowder calls it mug
club you should call
us the beanie bros you know we did have
a conversation about like making
membership name something and i was like
there's going to come a point where we
have many more shows
and people will just be like what is
that imagine going like disney plus and
it's called like the mickey face
and be like like be a mickey mouse club
yeah that would join join the doing the
musketeers you'd be like
no i guess no no no
all right ace 2020 boyd says youtube is
crazy they can put strikes on crowder
but allow
nakey yoga videos with full frontal no
blurs also won't let me send this with
the full words right
huh dude there's really messed up videos
there's videos where
a guy does like what's in my butt
challenge
they show it whoa yep they show it
yeah they actually show his butt well
cringe
they don't show like they they show it
from a
perspective where it's like you can tell
what they're doing they say what they're
doing
so crowder actually had a segment where
they actually
showed some of the highly objectionable
material that you could find on youtube
and i don't think youtube liked that
very much
no but i mean they should have said
thank you you know i don't have to hire
somebody to
police my own yep but don jet says
cicadas contain high levels of mercury
i don't think eating a bunch of them is
wise shout out to ian from cuyahoga
falls
monroe falls avenue what's up you ever
go to monroe falls
lake and take a dip that's where i used
to get shaved ice right over there
oh cool yeah i have no idea what you
just said
oh that's my my hometown shout out to my
homies calgary falls ohio
what's up ashley hayes says ky masks end
june 11th look into andrew cooper rider
of brood in lexington took the fight to
andy
bashir his weekly protests
built his own cc processing service
after being banned from stripe
and paypal he is leading project
uncountable
uncancelable in ky interesting cool
jellybeans says hey tim fellow illinois
citizen here i'm from the suburbs
however orlando park area oak forest to
be exact
i work in joliet new lenox area and i
paid 3.17 cents a gallon
i thought illinois wasn't one of the
states affected by the pipeline issues
maybe the pipeline issues there's more
to the story than they're telling us
but i know all of those areas very well
it's getting a lot of them
dane shell says the left is doing what
libertarians couldn't and that's break
down the system enough for a new
generation to have a clean slate
the great reset but doing it with bad
fuel unscalable ideologies
i mean it to a certain degree but
they're like
kneecapping the police and then
replacing them with woke police so it's
not
gonna get better it's just getting worse
are those woke police disarmed
no they're armed okay so yeah that's
pretty that's pretty terrifying yeah
that's not good kev says first super
chat ever what good is a functioning
pipeline if the billing software has
been encrypted and you can't bill your
customers
they paid the rams the ransom within
three hours according to numerous
reports
so they weren't dealing with that
no idea
nicholas nasty says the purpose of the
purpose of the second amendment is to
guarantee that the people have
any necessary implement to overthrow a
tyrannical government
zero limitations this is only partially
true
i i'm not a fan of when people are like
it's to overthrow tyrannical government
no it was literally just to defend
yourself period tyrannical government
or invading force or lunatic criminal
a free state requires a well-regulated
militia
therefore the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
people need to understand there were no
police back then it was all local
militia
when there was like a robbery people
would round up the boys
and they would be like hey get the
militia yeah the second amendment is a
poem to the people to remind them that
they are free and it's a prohibition
against the state
yep
marco says i have a question for forrest
mainly with all the critical race theory
and other agendas in the army being
pushed would you still join the rangers
love the show oof that is a good
question
you're gonna have to have a small
challenge between two decisions one of
them
i can answer for you if you're going to
join the rangers absolutely if you're
not getting if you're interested in
joining the military right now you have
to go special operations ranger
battalion navy seals special forces
marsoc
it's going to trust me every the
military is all moving in that direction
the
global war on terror is known as the
rise of the special operation so
if you're thinking about joining the
military and you haven't looked at
special operations
absolutely what's what's marsoc marstock
would be this
marine version of special operations
their their contribution
or their contribution so all right
second one
looking at critical race theory in the
military if you believe that you have
the moral integrity to resist
the the push of critical race theory yes
but that has to be a very serious and
personal question
if you if you are if you think that
you're going or
yeah does that does that answer the
question yeah like you it is a very
serious question
take it seriously why did you why are
you joining the military is it out of
patriotism is it out of duty
those are easy answers to say on paper
but when you actually have to live them
out
all right ossary says great guest
we vets and country boys will be the
ones to survive when the energy hits the
fan
dude you guys are constantly hyping
ian's bread and i'm yearning for a road
trip and i'm not even a big bread eater
so we are currently building out as part
of the new website an auction feature
which is going to allow us to do a
two-tiered
ticket system for the house so we want
to do friday night events
every friday 10 tickets first come first
serve
and then probably 10 maybe more tickets
that are top auction based
this way you have the people who are
like spamming the refresh button because
we can
we only have certain capacity it's not
it's not like we have that much space so
we have to figure out a way to make it
fair and i'm like
two-tier system works because then you
have people who can
afford to mosey on over not really worry
about time and
make their bid and spend more to come
but then people who probably can't
afford to can just try and
use merit just get that ticket first
it'll be difficult and we'll put in
restrictions so that
some people don't come every single time
we get more opportunities
but the auction system allows us to
basically do anything so we can auction
off a loaf of ian bread
stored properly in dry ice now i don't
know what the regulations are
right because it might be like a
donation it might have to be just like
ian as a person sending a person no no
the business will be able to do the
auction i will make
several at least three loaves of bread
for that event and then we'll have to
put oh yeah then we'll just slice them
into quarters we'll slice the breads
into halves
we'll do like a garlic bread we'll do a
cinnamon raisin maybe make sandwiches
maple we'll have we'll have sandwiches
ready and bread is
good it's it is it is it makes like
store-bought bread just like i mean
there's no preservatives this is the
thing the store-bought bread has natural
they put preservatives in it so it can
last on the shelf this stuff
goes stale after five days if you leave
it out even if you have it in a bread
box yeah you got to eat it man if you
did in the first two days
it's amazing it is just moist and it
just holds the
you can't explain it with words you guys
you you really want to come to these
events
so we're we're in the process of setting
things up so that we can actually do
this we just had it we just had the
driveway redone we just had some work
done the garage
there's still a process i know we wanted
to do this back in february
and then i'm like we should have public
events and then we had like a legal
conversation and i was like
huh we can't we still have to overcome
some hurdles business-wise
and so we're all working on the things
with the checklist to get everything
done and it takes a long time man
it's too bad you know it's in the real
world you can't just do things
think uh most people learn that these
business these business people think
it's like well i know how to make a
business work they get into government
then all of a sudden everything sludges
up
they don't realize that once you get
government involved it's just like
i could theoretically be like come on
down and then we'd be shut down in two
seconds
so fortunately
all right where are we at
philip snow says love the show did
anyone else see the vaccine concert
sponsored by youtube last week
talk about serious propaganda the whole
thing without getting people vaccinated
even biden and kamala were part of it
it's the craziest thing to me because
it's weird that you've got everyone
advocating for a medication
when people should be advised to go and
talk to their medical professionals
their doctors
when donald trump talked about
hydroxychloroquine they were screaming
at top of their lungs
like he's going to get people hurt don't
do this the same thing is true for any
medication
all of a sudden they flip their tune
it's like oh now it's fine now just
ignore
no no no you go to your doctor you ask
you ask your doctor what's up because i
think it's ridiculous
yeah stop treating the politicians the
political class as your high priest
like scarier is that four
says good on you for having recoil on
met two of their guys at a training
course cool dudes
get knowledge and skills you bet
thanks
pdog says if you want a depiction of
life without electricity read the going
home series by american
really makes you think about how people
would act also michael knowles book
speechless is available for pre-order on
amazon
ding that dude is going to sell so many
books yeah ding
speechless they just put it in at the
end and then i have to read it i love it
so much doc lock says fifteen hundred
dollar pew pew device voucher
take it to the pew pew store for your
pew pew of choice yearly 500 round box
of ammo for training and supply
buy annual mandatory pp training
national defense budget
i i don't know training i just i agree
with don't
don't ever don't ever put the state in
charge of training yeah exactly when you
go
when you go to the dmv maybe if you're
gonna get a gun from the government
you've got to do a general firing test
like yeah like a driving test
exactly like you walk up and you have
your handgun and you have your your ar
and they do like some basic range or
whatever some low range
seven yards and what maybe like 21 for
the rifle and then they test you and if
you
are good enough they're like you pass
have a nice day so you'll have to load
the gun
they'll watch you load it just make sure
you know how don't don't you'll have to
turn the safety off
make sure you know how and then you'll
have to hit the target yeah
i mean that's that's all they already
make you do that in minnesota for
concealed carry or
permit to carry so you go to the dgs and
instead of like a driving test you just
you fill a little piece of paper and
they call you into the range and then
you
do a function test fire and then so
they're being immediate failures like a
rolling stop if you don't stop
completely to stop sign that's an
automatic failure
yeah but you can take the test again
yeah so then you're like okay
so it'd be pretty easy to do yeah i mean
this it does sound like a good idea so
long as it's mandatory that the state
give out firearms but
or you know order like proof of proof
proving it over there i just don't want
the state telling me what i can and
cannot do when the state can't figure
out
you know everything i think if they're
gonna give you
something a test isn't a big deal
because you always have the choice to go
buy one your own
sure so if it's like you want your free
gun from the government you go there's a
range there you gotta
you know what's the test to get on
welfare um
you have to go to the department of
health and human services and then they
ask you a series of questions
that you don't you can lie about well i
mean you can lie about a lot whatever
you want i mean if you want to break the
law you can break the law
so sure yeah but if it's like if you're
going to be getting free stuff you know
i'm just saying piracy is in fashion
yeah
all right let's see justin heasley says
tim and forrest why is the requirement
of a firearm training class not
necessarily supported by
by pro 2a personalities yeah
i can answer that one it's because we
don't want the state to tell us what is
the requirement like
so if you're going to come and take a
class or if you're going to go get your
concealed carry like absolutely that's
the bare minimum
so but you should be pursuing becoming
better at something you should be
pursuing taking other taxes
requires but i do not think i do not
because who determines what the test is
yeah sure in order to get a gun you have
to sit through eight hours of critical
race theory
yep or i think it's reasonable that
people have a training course
that they pass a training course in
order to get a firearm don't you agree
and they say yes okay
now to pass the course we're gonna give
you a a you know nine millimeter we're
gonna give you a glock and you gotta hit
the center of the target at 100 yards
i can't do that you get one round yeah i
can't do that right now i mean i can
um so it's like oh okay like well if you
can't do it you shouldn't have a gun
yeah like it can it can be used as a
prohibition right so
a common thing that's said in the uh
that that's used in
a kind of a trendy conversation that
people say right now is like oh well the
hor
the history of gun control is rooted in
racism
i think this is a bad argument i get the
point but i think it's a bad argument
because
the origins of american the american
version of gun control
was originally intended to target
certain ethnic
minorities the problem wasn't only that
it was targeting ethnic minorities but
it actually was also
disarming a population the problem is
the disarmament
so the application of one group of
people making up a list of rules that
you have to meet in order to be
like them is wrong it is
fundamentally tyranny to support gun
control
all right we got andrew j gregory says
tim saw your blog
where you guys were playing music i'm
from md and would love to jam with you
guys
i've played drums on and off since i was
16 30 year old now um
send us an email all right we'll just do
a couple more let's see
jonathan duggar says did time and kaf if
minneapolis is anything like that
leaving is a good choice army leads the
way
thank you hot dog 400 says
tim you bring up a good point get rid of
police bring back local militia
i'm pretty sure the left would agree
with that because well they probably
would because they're lying
but one of the arguments is that
community policing you have cops from
outside towns and areas coming in and
forcing the law and not caring about the
community and it's like
okay local militia yeah right don't make
the uh the marxist mistake of an
argument of a good assessment of the
problem means that you're going to have
an excellent solution
all right one more aaron says raising
amden geese
and guinea fowl is that what that giant
is guinea skinny
if everything turns out right we have
entertainment in our backyards
if there's a spike in food prices we
have a self-perpetu
perpetrating fortune in our backyards
there you go they're also alarm dogs
yeah loud guinea hens yeah they're not
very intelligent
no the chickens man wow it's it's
hilarious watching these things they
love music
yeah you were you were singing them yeah
they came over and sat down one by one
and then just
chilled and farmed and watched i've i've
watched uh when i when i was a kid we
had a dog and our dog actually
called the guinea hens from the
neighbors farm into our
property and then ate them whoa oh my
gosh i'll cross the highway yeah wow it
would sit there it was the weirdest
thing because
of them it would it would sit way out in
the field and it'd make noise you could
see it barking and making this noise
and then and then you'd see the skinny
hand walk across
well that dog was really really smart
after uh
after ian said that i went out the
guitar and i jammed and vanessa walked
over and sat down
and just like hung out and watched me
jam yeah she's she's going to have a
character arc
yeah i like vanessa so i was wrong she's
not mean
vanessa yeah i was i was yes francis
chicken uh i i said the other day that
she was like being mean no i was
incorrect what's she doing
no she was just uh um i think i mistook
her demands for food to be
bullying oh so she when she would come
up and follow me around and stuff i
thought she was like
getting ready to oh turns out she just
wanted more stink bugs all right
vanessa and then you know she's very
nice we have a competitor lead the way
my friends if you have not already make
sure you smash the like button and you
can follow this show on facebook
facebook.com
tim cast irl where we will leverage the
network to
if you could share the videos get more
people to go over to timcast.com so it's
greatly appreciated we're also on
instagram at tim cast irl
this show is live monday through friday
at 8 p.m so of course we're back
tomorrow
and uh did you want to shout anything
out for us your social media so my
like i said my personal social media is
fox foxpro official with an underscore
in there it's really annoying but it's a
pretty casual page
but the bigger thing and the more
important thing is follow recoil
magazine on instagram
and then if you actually want to best
way to get our magazine is actually just
to subscribe you can subscribe to it
it's cheaper it gets delivered to your
door
it's discreet and so but check out check
out our website
recoilweb.com and offgridweb.com okay
thanks and i'm ian crossland you can
follow me
in crossland.net and along social media
at ian crossland so thanks for coming
cool yeah i'm always glad to have an
expert in his field on the show with us
and i thank you guys very much for
supporting us as crowder is going
through this this does concern me a lot
you guys can follow me on twitter at
patch lids in my quest to have more
followers than sour patch kids
go over to timcast.com click the members
only button
sign up now because at around 11 we're
gonna have an exclusive members only
segment up with forrest from recruit
magazine so thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all there bye guys
you